there's no time o clock
[Music]
hey it's episode 184 yeah this guy here
man John Wayne Gacy
we're finally getting around to like I
said I think we started out the show
like with all these kind of lesser-known
currents and like lesser-known serial
killers had never haven't like circle
back and like do and all these like big
well then once well we had a we had a
small subscriber base and in order to
give us any kind of notoriety and the
algorithms we were going for rare cases
first that's what I figured I figured I
would just talk although it's probably
[ __ ] stupid it's probably smarter
just go for the big cases that would
probably move us up the algorithms for
all I know well I don't know because
that's the thing it's like yeah you can
do that but you and like everyone and
their mother has done them so I don't
know how it worked out we just the show
just evolved normally yeah natural yeah
yeah we normally doesn't normal about
this yeah nothing's normal about you
Thomas
yeah and it's definitely nothing normal
about nature alright so John Wayne Gacy
is also not normal no [ __ ] no was
also not normal dude he that's deceased
he's deceased thankfully talk about it
yeah this guy [ __ ] hell 33 murderers
that they know of that was all he
admitted two young guys he likes young
guys and boys some of them are like
teenage boys yeah and yeah really
special and he was kind of one of those
guys that no one suspected a thing cuz
everyone just thought he was totally rad
yeah he had a construction company and
you know was making some money and he
dress up as a clown and [ __ ] I think
this is you know it's I think that's now
red flag if you if you dress up as a
clown well now it is because of this
douche that's probably why I wonder if
like I wonder
[ __ ] up the club that's what I mean
now it's like I I would love to see
that's it has anybody written a book or
an essay or anything like that about
people that were like clowns like a
clown college and everything like that
if after Chuck get arrested and they
found out about him did they be like
[ __ ] yeah I don't know you've just
ruined our whole entire livelihood now
we can't go to children's birthday
parties anymore because everyone thinks
were gonna be murder clowns yeah because
this was before Stephen King's it came
out yeah and his character was called
Pogo okay he had one called patches two
had just which it I don't know how
different that one was then it's funny
because I was I was watching a
documentary I've watched like a whole
bunch of documentaries about this dude
and like apparently people that are like
you know went to Clown College and are
like really into that kind of stuff they
said well the way that he did his Pogo
clown makeup with the pointy mouth kind
of it's like yeah we would never do that
it's like clowns always use like soft
edges like round edges because it's not
as terrifying yeah so even they know
that scary
what he do is you start hanging out with
you you know and if you were a cute guy
and he wanted your booty he'd sit there
and frickin show you magic tricks with
you with with handcuffs yeah because he
could escape from handcuffs and then
he'd teach you how to do it or whatever
and then he put him on you and then but
he you couldn't get out well it's cuz he
switched the handcuffs yep he put real
handcuffs on you as to the fake
handcuffs and once he of those handcuffs
are on you
oh man yeah you know you were gone this
is gone and this do is like a brutal
rapist man he'd put anything I'd be in
your booty evidently pretty much yeah
yeah and and the weird thing like I said
the weirdest thing about him the thing
that always strikes me as being the
weirdest thing about him is that no one
suspected anything no one suspected
anything they'd receive was just like a
normal dude it's like oh he was like all
into the [ __ ] he was in the Jaycees
and he was like [ __ ] and you know
what I mean he had a wife and kids and
you know I mean he was kind of a short
stocky guy and um - yeah you know he
kind of carried himself kind of like a
toughy you know he was
I kind of had kind of tough accent a
certain way you know from the from from
what I remember hearing you know is his
voice and a suit he's got those
handcuffs on you became [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz this dude was like a power top you
know I'm talking you know there's like a
top and a bottom but he was like this
dude was super [ __ ] dominant yeah I
was gonna show you what a [ __ ] you were
yeah and I think a lot of that probably
stem from his childhood yeah we'll talk
about matarile he was [ __ ] not what
he called it sadistic to do is sadistic
yeah and like I said his ass whipped he
did it is a disaster his needed his ass
killed is what he did it that's what
should have this yeah and sadly it's
unfortunate that I mean during the time
that he was committing these crimes in
the early to late 1970s it seemed like
even though he had been arrested in his
early days like before he killed anyone
for various like sexual transgressions
very sexual assaults and things like
that um no one really thought anything
about it like you know what I mean no
one stopped him know it's like nowadays
if you like raped a boy like that you
would be on a sexual predator list like
forever and like everywhere you went
everyone would know but it's like back
in the 70s they didn't keep track of
that [ __ ] you just you know they didn't
know until they checked like later like
way later on and the shitty thing too
was that since he was targeting you know
teenage boys the cops had a real kind of
like laid-back attitude aside teenage
boys their run away all the time he'll
be back
I think part of the problem is that they
know he won't most of these cops didn't
know anything about serial offenders
yeah didn't even have a concept of a
serial offender they weren't really
trained to see crime that way they were
trained to see crime as an individual
occurrence yeah how would it how would
the court systems how would they
interpret this individual occurrence
yeah I mean so if they couldn't get you
on one thing then it was gone yeah later
on you did it again if they couldn't get
you on that then it was just gone
there wasn't a system to keep track of
how many times you got away with
something yeah because I mean yeah like
you said it's early 70s and if you
scene like [ __ ] mine hunter and all
that good stuff this was the very
infancy of like the serial killer you
know the FBI like kind of establishing
their serial killer like you know yeah
protocol do they didn't really know much
about it at the time during that era you
know he would have had a much better
chance probably being caught if he was
in more of a rural area because local
sheriffs were the ones that were really
kind of more apt to work - who the
they're more apt to figure out who the
habitual offenders were because they
personally knew the people right so they
can keep an eye on them you know but if
you were in a suburban or an urban area
it was just there was no way to keep
track of a guy yeah there's millions of
them out there a local sheriff mine oh I
know who did that that's dead yeah let's
get Sam's house yeah hey we heard about
this [ __ ] that raw and that sounds like
some [ __ ] that you would you do yeah
yeah if that had been done like I said
hindsight's 20/20 but had that been done
in this case maybe a lot of people would
still be alive that's all I'm saying
but you know what you gotta do any
shoutouts yes I have one shout out one
of our patrons fade has increased his
support this week or our support I'm not
really sure if it's I mean oh yeah
that's right okay yeah so what then I
will send you fade fade that's a cool
name actually yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so thank you very much for that I mean
they were already giving like a lot and
then they gave like that's like really
cool but yeah so we have a patreon you
know just in case yeah go over there and
you guys want to support the show please
hit us up on Pedro yeah that would be
really read also just in the mail today
I got this DVD right here it is Twilight
Zone movies right yeah it's a Korean
edition it is there's Korea all over it
yeah which yeah I am very very excited
to watch this this was one of my very
favorite movies when I was younger
had it on VHS I recorded it from HBO or
Cinemax or whatever and I saw it
probably about 50,000 times yeah
approximately so we will probably be
reviewing that in a week or two we still
have to do 30 days of I've never seen
you have never seen I've never seen the
movie no that's that's a Korean edition
because Korea loves sucking classic
American movies so they'll order a batch
of them every now and then the ones that
don't sell and they'll come back to the
US market yeah I've seen a lot of stuff
and special editions for me really like
the whole scene in the cards like Dan
Aykroyd if you want to see something
really scary you never saw that mmm no
[ __ ] all right we're gonna watch this
[ __ ] later like after we finished
recording this all right so let's start
talking about [ __ ] John Wayne Gacy
yeah one of the most prolific serial
killers like I said they know that he
killed 33 most of them hey Barry just in
the crawlspace under his house yeah I
can't believe me and it was just there
for a long time and nobody knew I don't
know how he kept the smell down you must
have had him wrap you know what he said
it's like when anybody like complained
about it because some people did because
he have like big [ __ ] this is like
some you know Edgar Allan Poe like
tell-tale heart [ __ ] right here it's
like so he has all these people like
buried in his [ __ ] crawlspace and he
has like big [ __ ] themed barbecues
and [ __ ] at his [ __ ] house like oh
it's a Hawaiian luau western barbecue or
whatever and it's like yes people come
over there and every now and then like
somebody be like may your house kind of
smells and he would say oh yeah well you
know the crawlspace it's like there's
like so much moisture down there or he
would like have some [ __ ] story about
like a sewer line breaking or some [ __ ]
like that even though obviously moisture
and decomposing bodies that was two
different smells so you know but nobody
even putting lie on them lime he put he
put lime on there but it clearly wasn't
working all that yeah because people
still did like so hot to change the
smell enough to maybe it didn't tell
what it was because some people did
comment on it at the time but geez but
you wouldn't think that like this
neighbor who by all accounts was like
just a cool guy neighborhood guy
knowing what the damn smell of a rotting
body smelled like I mean back on the
railroad tracks with a damn dead dogs we
used to find it that's a very distinct
jr. as a 10 year old boy we could sniff
em out miles away - yeah there's when
I'm dead up there let's go fight you
know I'm just I'm telling stories but no
we knew we knew we could tell Dicky and
we're going to our Walkman we can we can
smell something's dead well yeah because
sometimes something like everybody knows
what that smell smells like yeah did you
I don't know why I just thought of like
Stephen King in I think it was in dance
McCobb where he was talking about when
he was a kid like him and his little
group of friends they would do the same
thing they would like look for like dead
yeah and then they would like do
experiments on it like hey if we drop a
brick on its ass will it [ __ ] like she'd
stuff like that the dim light of the day
we shoes are different
well there was kind of like a group
agreement you know me Jimmy and Mike
there was three of us we were all by
about 10 at that time 8 between 8 and 10
um there was a day we just decided
that's it no more [ __ ] around with
dead stuff we found a vacant German
Shepherd up on the railroad tracks and
he was robbed he was rotting and hair it
all kind of fallen off of him and Jim
Jimmy says turn him over so I found a
big old [ __ ] stick it was probably
about like foot long stick that we found
and I put it underneath it and turn it
over and it was just a man just like a
whole dam that I'll get full of maggots
literally boiling oh man and we all
instantly all just threw up and that's
it we gave up that we gave up the dead
dog you learn to value us and that
because it was hot I mean okay and they
were underneath that thing eating up in
the inside it was almost hollow you know
I thought about that's how I remembered
it when he flipped it over all that
[ __ ] magazine that was at me you know
and that was the last day we messed with
that do that we gave it up
that I don't like I'm not squeamish come
on I don't go out of my way like looking
for that oh we did well okay
three people who saw Terminator 2 you
know the flat they you know the big
chase scene where our knees on the
motorcycle he's in a big concrete yeah
okay that's that was called the flood
controls that's what we called it yeah I
think everybody called it the flood
control system it's where the giant ants
lived from them in that where they
filmed that the car race in Greece
office yeah it's really exactly well we
would what followed the railroad tracks
down to that place because in Long Beach
California and it was also wildlife
preserves back there or preserves I've
called them preserves but we called it
preserve we were looking preserve
resources as a little kid you know we've
got a wildlife reserves down there and
it was basically kind of like a marsh
that went up to about your knee when you
were a kid maybe up to your waist cuz
we'd go swimming in it and stuff and
there was fish in it you know it's just
that was just what how we grew up as
kids and so taking the railroad tracks
was about getting to the wildlife
reserve and many were bullfrogs down
there the size of [ __ ] cow [ __ ] you
know I'm talking to the buck the size
but yeah there's some yeah yeah we try
to eat them and stuff you know I mean we
never get the seasoning right with
little kids trying to barbecue the damn
frog yeah you have a rod check cuz we
were [ __ ] boys stealing gasoline and
going inside the tunnels looking for the
giant ants we did that did all kinds of
stuff because we needed the gasoline for
the torches well I get that yeah and the
stuff that kinda [ __ ] I get like it you
know I used to session on fire and stuff
too but eating frogs yeah that wouldn't
occur to me yeah just a leg I would just
leave the Frog alone the Frog is fine
just the legs and I feel like hey little
buddy got the whole frog just the legs
well he needs his legs now we killed the
Frog why did you do that to eat legs
we'd catch the frogs and kill the frogs
and then are you sure you're not a
serial killer
no we were just frog legs you know we
were also [ __ ] hand catch crawfish
and try to eat those yeah okay yeah then
out of that same wild well that yeah
that I can see but like if it's like a
big
frog there's cute there were lots of
them there you know man it wasn't like
mover nobody else was he there's lots of
people too nobody else killing them
nobody else nobody else was eat I was
like when you were talking about um when
we were walking on the path yeah you
know and smell and dead stuff and
everything I don't know why I just
thought of this but remember I told you
other morning I was walking along the
path and this [ __ ] squirrel ran
across the path in front of me and a
[ __ ] hawk swooped down and grabbed
the squirrel and that [ __ ] squirrel
fought like hell he was just like
scratching it and the squirrel looks
like really smart he ran into this big
cuz there been a storm the night before
and there was like all kind of like
branches and [ __ ] leaves everywhere
like all over the ground
that squirrel like douve right into this
big branch that was all like that and
he'd over right in the middle of it and
the hawk caught caught yeah in the thing
and the hawk was like [ __ ] man and Hawk
couldn't get out and I think the
squirrel got away because then I saw the
hawk like he need flew up on the little
mound there and he's like looking around
[ __ ] well I don't know like the
squirrel might have been hurt because
she don't say they do the talons and
anyway I know and that's kind of sad but
you can see how like the little [ __ ]
are pretty smart though because he's
like well I'm gonna go in here and get
his [ __ ] little talons all caught up
in the tree and it worked
yeah I don't know I've shot squirrels
before they ran away yeah yeah I think
to live a 22 we'll go right through him
without doing much damage yes my feels
like it's just a flesh wound went out
there well back in my tree that was a
day that I went out there and [ __ ] all
y'all I killed about 20 or 30 of them I
had a whole belt full of damn dead
squirrels I look like I was wearing a
first query's yeah I took him back took
him back to my dad's house cleaned him
and dressed him and made a squirrel stew
and didn't even get full off even thirty
[ __ ] squirrels there's no I gave up
killing squirrels that's too it's too
much death and destruction for an
unsatisfying me and they're so cute yeah
maybe no don't you yeah I don't want to
that's what I mean it's like that's all
you know yeah and shoot him with a 22 so
he's had to shoot him three times it
would just go right through them and
they get a rock that's like not worth it
but worth it
I felt like a murderer at the end I was
like man why should I kill one deer and
actually and they're big yeah yeah and
till one dare to eat for [ __ ] a might
this is a squirrel apocalypse like I
even get enough food because they're
small yeah
it just seems like they why would you
even bother they're just tree rats
really are adorable they're tree rats a
sophisticated pretty tree rat that's
what they are but still they are little
creatures and they are kind of cute so
there's no reason you know I mean only
in a in a very only a dire starving to
death fine yeah but you know what I mean
only in a dire emergency right plus I
feel like they're so off topic I know
we're blessed I feel like they're like
way more intelligent than they are given
credit for their the American monkey
yeah basically pretty much yeah all
right so what you want to talk about
John Wayne Gacy yeah we're gonna keep
this show down under three hours tonight
alright so let's talk about John Wayne
Gacy 'he's early life now by most
accounts he had a fairly normal
childhood fairly normal um he didn't
have any of your big danger signs like
as far as I know he didn't like [ __ ]
like kill small animals or he didn't
know his dad was kind of like abusive
but we'll get into that a little bit so
he's born in Chicago in 1942 now he was
the middle child he also had a younger
sister and an older sister now his dad
whose name was also John Stanley Gacy he
was a like a auto repair guy or
something like that he had been in World
War one
and apparently he was one of those dudes
there was a lot of these back in the day
um he was real like everyone has to be
like the manliest man that ever manned
yeah you can't have any like feminine
quote-unquote tendencies at all okay
yeah okay so time I've ever seen that
that dudes of that dudes gay well yeah
that guy who's a hyper worried about
[ __ ] whether or not you have damn
feminine
that's like worried about it I kind of
figure out who he can [ __ ] that's all
he's like I feel like this maybe this is
why you had a lot of these types of
serial killers like back in this day
because when their dads we're raising
them a lot of their dads were kind of
like this their dads were well he was an
alcoholic I think also he was apparently
according to John Wayne Gacy he was
verbally and physically abusive to both
his mother and the children I don't know
about the daughters but he did kind of
beat up on John Wayne Gacy and he was
one of those dudes that was like
everything is like Oh your [ __ ] you
know what I mean so John Wayne Gacy he
was you know he was a little bit chubby
when he was a kid he wasn't real
athletic he wasn't you know
quote/unquote manly enough so the dad
was like every single thing he did he
just called him stupid all the time it's
like that he would never amount to
anything and all this other kind of
stuff then that just never as well you
know what I mean um apparently John
Wayne Gacy had a very good relationship
with his mom and his two daughters
however and the weird thing about it is
though even though his dad was
apparently kind of a [ __ ] to him John
Wayne Gacy apparently like really really
loved and worshipped his father and
spent most of his life seeking his
approval which i sweared [ __ ] though
seems to be like one of where one of his
life problems came yeah but you know
yeah it just it seemed really weird like
he had a tough dad yeah and he even said
like later on he's like I didn't hate my
dad like his shitty as his dad was to
him yeah he had a tough dad who
constantly talked about yeah and I put
him in kind of like this submissive
position to his dad in a way where he
was always trying to please him that's
what happened there yeah that seems like
exactly what it was his dad his dad's
approval was unattainable so in a way he
was raised trying to attain the
appreciation of
yeah I guess you could put it that way
that's and that's I might be
psychologically setting you up for four
you know what I mean
the kind of attractions he was into it
could be yeah you want to take your
dad's role yours all about yeah you want
to take his place and his place is to
have him a boy worshiping him okay yeah
and and and and and and being
appreciative of his power
well you if you don't you know what I
mean so what do you did what he's doing
is this he's basically started off as
kind of like sexually intimidating these
boys yeah you know I mean to try to kind
of recreate that or to recreate his
dad's power that does seem to be kind of
my happiness doing because it seemed
like a lot of the victims that he would
target were younger teenage boys and he
liked them you know probably for obvious
and maybe not so obvious reasons he he
likes them very thin and small well
that's because he didn't want anybody
that could like fight back against em
it's were yeah cuz when they were
standing next to him they were with next
RAM so that's what he's doing man he's
trying to recreate that he's trying to
recreate his dad's power he's trying to
become like his dad was yeah which like
I said in a way maybe it would have been
better if he had hated his dad
yeah instead of you know apparently
really really loving his dad and wanting
his dad's approval I'm thinking that
this boy will love him it could be it
could be that that's what he's trying to
like recreate but then when that doesn't
work out he kills a kid yeah see that
might be what it's what's happened it's
not kind of be gonna be something kind
of like that man
so apparently like I said the dad like
would you know beat him with straps it's
like he kept saying that his sister's
were better than him that he was stupid
and like he would never be good enough
[ __ ] like that
you know what I mean and then like
his mom would intervene and like try to
get her husband like stop beatin on the
kid and then the dad would like it would
get even worse because then dad would
say like oh you'll just grow queer
you're a mama's boy bla bla bla so all
that kind of stuff
raise your kids right folks you know you
don't want him to turn out like Sean
Casey I got it I've already got I've
already got this great suspicion that
that John's [ __ ] dad is closeted gay
self-hating closeted gay it may be
because it's like why I don't understand
why he's focusing in on them I'm not
saying that everybody that is homophobic
or whatever is a closeted gay because
that would just be ridiculous and that's
but it does seem like the ones who are
most vehement about it yeah most of this
think about it because you're gay I
don't really understand why anyone would
care what other people are doing with
their own buttholes or their own vaginas
or whatever I don't care that's what I
mean that's like why would anyone care
it's none of my other gay dudes care you
know other gay dudes care gay dudes care
about other gay dudes well whatever you
have a gay dude who's a self-hating gay
dude so he's got to punish all these
other guys that's what I mean and I do
feel like that's what - is going on the
matter I'm explaining geology now so
apparently um John Wayne Gacy when he
was a kid like this happened in 1949 now
apparently him and a little friend of
his got caught molesting a little girl
now apparently like Gacy got whipped as
punishment for that now according to him
and according to a couple of other
family friends Gacy was also molested by
a friend of theirs like a friend of the
family he was also a contractor and he
would like take Gacy out like for rides
in the truck and everything like that
and would end up molesting him so that
kind of happened as well apparently Gacy
said he never told his dad about any of
that because he knew he would get beat
for it now
Gacy also had a heart condition
and because of this he was advised by
his doctors to not participate in any
like you know strenuous sports or any
kind of activity like that in school um
so he kind of got he wasn't like um a
fat kid you know what I mean he was a
little bit chunky but not anything that
would have been but apparently like
because he didn't play sports because he
had a heart condition because so he kind
of got picked on a little bit it seems
like by other kids but all of his
teachers and stuff like that seemed to
really like him because apparently he
was he he not real brilliant he had like
a little bit above average IQ but
apparently he was real eager to please
and he would like help out like with the
truancy officer and he was like he was
kind of like a teacher's pet type of kid
now during the 4th grade like right
about the time which if you're not in
the United States 4th grade is what
eight nine nine something like that
about nine years old yeah um so he
starts having blackouts now this I've
seen different sources for this might
have been from some of his dad's
beatings but I've also seen that when he
was about this age he got hit in the
head with a swing when he was 10 or 11
and it like kind of busted his head so
here's our old friend head injury again
just like we talked about was a lot of
other serial killers very common that's
the eternal 12-pack after I got a head
that motorcycle accident and everything
for about three years I felt like I was
I had drank a 12-pack not three years
probably a year yeah so it does mess
your it does measure yeah your
inhibitions [ __ ] you know kind of like
a [ __ ] and I guess if you already
have inclinations in that direction
right and you have a head injury on top
of it and you have an abusive father on
top of that then that's like a recipe
for disaster clearly yeah but yeah so
whether it was that or something else
apparently he had a blood clot in his
brain for several years that I believe
was undiagnosed for about five years in
there like from when he was about ten or
eleven till he was about sick
Steen and it was causing like blackout
seizures headaches like all this kind of
stuff now he also had like some other
like I said he also in a heart condition
he had a burst appendix in 1957 so he
had to be hospitalized for that so he
was in and out of the hospital a lot
because he had like a lot of health
issues and apparently that was another
thing that his dad was like picking on
about because he thought he was like
faking everything I don't know how you
faked a burst appendix or a blow your
brain I'm telling you man his dad his
dad is gonna be a key thing and in
John's [ __ ] activity you know yeah his
psychology is sucking being forged by
this guy's sanity that's what so I could
have it yeah that's what I mean and I
just had this you guys I just be really
careful I eraser yeah we got we got
bucking we got gay subscribers regulars
I'm gonna ask them yeah some of them got
me out Tom shitty movies and Facebook do
you think John Wayne Gacy dad is gay you
can put that in the damn comment
sections I'm going to I think he is I
bet you they're gonna say the same thing
I think you're dealing with like a
closeted leather daddy yeah we're the
kind of like this weird incestuous kind
of thing where he doesn't want to have
sex with this continent he's not gonna
openly to have sex with his son you got
punish him and there's a lotta like a
little bit of a sexual kind of a weird
flavor to it and in some way John's
loving this it's just some kind of weird
twisted [ __ ] relationship that's what
I mean most guys don't give a [ __ ]
enough to go through this they don't
scare ya and you see this over and over
again yeah like with with people that
become serial killers later on it's like
not only the whole head injury thing
because a lot of people have header
injuries yes they don't all being serial
killers but it's like you see this kind
of like messed up family dynamic which
that's not normal y'all know it's like
everyone's family is dysfunctional to
agree to a degree
you know everyday people are like that
because everyone's dysfunctional
everybody has something wrong with them
nobody's perfect and stuff like that but
it's like you know you try to get by as
best you can but it's like I don't know
like I feel like you read about this
kind of [ __ ] and there's just always
some kind of like [ __ ] weird there's
almost like a weird like sexual dynamic
or they have a weird like I don't know
there's some it's it's seems slightly
sexual and it seems you know it's
sadistic yeah
what he's doing - yeah and I'm just
telling you yeah there's more than me so
I yeah I I wouldn't doubt it yeah so now
apparently Gacy never actually finished
high school
however when he was 18 years old in 1960
he kind of was very interested in
politics so he started working for the
Democratic Party in Chicago as an
assistant precinct captain now his dad
didn't like this either that was also
[ __ ] apparently I don't really know
tell you go back to that day it goes
back to that [ __ ] like [ __ ] he's gay
he's worried about that [ __ ] too much no
normal person work no house when I was
back in the Army I was I was in the
infantry during the Don't Ask Don't Tell
era yeah other man if gays were allowed
but you couldn't but you were allowed to
like be open about it right which that
can be missed Internet's been
misinterpreted you know in recent years
no there were gays in our unit we knew
who they were but it nobody gave a [ __ ]
yeah just as long as it was [ __ ]
closeted because we had to have it put
on a professional military appearance
and really the biggest fear with all
that [ __ ] is that they don't want it to
where they don't want a system to where
in order to get promoted you got to
screw some dude that's really all it is
about yeah that's what they're trying to
prevent because that has happened in
other armies German army actually in the
30s of the 40 sorry dude
don't don't understand that well it
wasn't really so much the German army it
was the SA which was a para men
Terry group that helped bring the Nazis
to power this is a lot of initiative
early Nazi did the early Nazis in the SA
and Hitler was involved we're a bunch of
leather daddies this is a game
ex-military man's group yes it was like
almost it was harkening back to like
spark ancient yes Bart it was that time
Howie Sparta and that's where their vibe
was going right and and it's something
that you don't see in American society
at least not yet was the idea of warrior
male homosexuality which was [ __ ]
around in in ancient Greece and Rome for
[ __ ] other countries for thousands of
years because it's just a bunch of men
locked up manly men amongst other manly
men doing manly manly manly [ __ ]
things and it's male supremest
women are nothing it's just how pretty
and powerful you are as a damn man yeah
that's what this [ __ ] whole thing was
about that's why they were raping each
other they raped [ __ ] dudes that
[ __ ] got defeated in battle so you
were fighting not only for your life but
for your ass yeah it was it's like some
[ __ ] up some kind of maximum-security
prison
all right and it can eventually get that
[ __ ] weird among men women do kind of
[ __ ] add some sanity to men yes sir
it's it's really funny because it's like
I in a way I'm very conflicted about
that troop because it does seem like wow
that's a lot of burden on women to like
civilize men because that does seem to
be like something that you take more
than expected but in a way there's like
there's a little bit of truth to that
because when there's women around men
tend to behave better yes yeah not
always I kind of but I grew up in
all-male Institute we are a civilizing
influence I grew up in all-male
institutions from an early age you know
military academies and stuff and we were
all good guys but yeah [ __ ] you know
I mean you get a bunch of guys together
for too long than the [ __ ] men on
their own go Lord of the Flies that
record time exactly record time exactly
they go very tribal [ __ ] die
you know when you get to any man all in
one spot just until like and all it
takes is like one girl to show up and go
what the [ __ ] are you doing and
everyone's all embarrassed suddenly so
[Laughter]
anyway I kind of suspect that this dude
is in that mode yeah John Wayne Gacy as
dad is one of these yeah like somebody
he'd find the SA yeah he sounded German
s like I said I think that so many like
serial killers dads were like this man
yeah [ __ ] hell just don't be like I
don't think anybody has to worry about
now Karl laughs one when you kind of
have these leftward kind of leaning
civilians so I can get bent out of shape
about gays in the military and they
don't understand what it was in military
was worried about they were worried
about gays in the military they're
worried about what happened in the essay
cuz they don't have a knowledge of
history
it'll be okay people on the Left don't
have a knowledge of history okay well no
they didn't have a knowledge of military
history of what was going on in the
essay you get a bunch of it and [ __ ] you
get a bunch of [ __ ] military men
together and it's a sexual situation it
goes bad goes sideways quick well
anytime men are together for any reason
it goes sideways quick I'm only just
gonna point it to Third Reich how that
came about and that was because extreme
male supremacism yeah really where that
[ __ ] comes from and in a way there's
kind of like a sexual tone in that
that's where that's coming from well
because you're trying to you're trying
to out man other yen yeah like I said
it's it goes back to [ __ ] in ancient
Greece right realm and becomes clear
that every where it becomes where men
are better than women yeah
and that women are unnecessary and that
the a man's power and his physical
appearance is better than a woman could
ever be that's why they're making those
damn statues yeah I know yeah so it can
get that extreme we were like women were
like oh versus just like cattle we
we only pray eventually gets to the
point to where the a woman's only
purpose is to breed men yeah they're
their men breeding pots yeah yeah super
fun ladies you got a watch you got to
watch it with that kind of thinking
because uh yeah not have a balanced
society you'll have some no [ __ ] yeah
that's not a good direction eventually
it gets to where all the women are
covered up and they just [ __ ] work at
home to raise children hopefully men and
they take care of the sheep and a
livestock matter of fact the sheep are
worth more that eventually can happen
which is hilarious to me because like I
don't know well the women aren't allowed
to work so they understand all that the
women aren't allowed to work in
societies like that because there's
totally male-dominated so the women
don't have any value in terms of income
they're not bringing anything to the
table in terms of income so there you
can buy and sell them and you know and
that shit's out there today I don't want
to name any names but it's a lot of
country there are countries that are
like that now you know yeah I'm like I
said yeah all right we're people - all
right hi but yeah so all right so
basically so Casey starts working for
like in politics or whatever now his dad
um I guess in a rare thing of sort of
generosity he buys him a car
however he puts the title in his own
name and he basically says Casey has to
make all the payments and it's like if
you don't make the payments on time and
take your keys so there was that whole
thing going on now apparently apparently
the dad had taken the keys like after he
didn't make a payment or something but
Casey it had extra keys made because
that's what you would do I mean that's
what I would have done like the first
thing and apparently his dad took the
distributor cap off there was like this
book and it was like a war of attrition
between these two so basically after the
distributor cap went back on because it
was apparently a big fight about this so
Casey's like [ __ ] this I'm out of here
so he drove to Las Vegas and he started
working for an ambulance service now
like I said he'd never graduated high
school he didn't get I think he got a
GED later off but he didn't have
any high school like he didn't have a
high school diploma so he goes and he
gets a job into ambulance service and
then he gets a job as like a janitor
slash attendant at a mortuary now he
works at this mortuary in Las Vegas for
three months I believe now it was kind
of like you know it was a pretty menial
job I think he lived on the premises
like he lived like in a room like with
all the bodies and stuff now apparently
and I guess he said this later on like
after he got caught that he got into the
coffin of a dead boy that was in there
and like fondled him and stuff damn
so yeah apparently that's I'm guessing
he said that so apparently this weird
and him out his own behavior weirded him
out and he called his mom and he said
hey like would dad like let me come home
cuz I don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on oh yeah um he was only about 18 at
the time 18 19 years old so he's just
just a protip you're 18 19 years old and
you actually have the idea to climb into
a coffin with a dead body yeah and feel
it up
you might need to like call someone
because that that's not what was weird
is like he did and he called his parents
in he said he asked his mom like would
dad let me come back this story is
coming from him yeah but I I think it's
been substantiated by other family
members I mean he's saying that he got
into the cup because I'm pretty sure
almost I'm presuming nobody saw him do
that it almost sounds like it's made up
but okay it well why would you admit to
about them yeah like yeah I climbed into
a coffee boys dead body did he make that
okay what was substantiate wasn't
something he said after he was caught to
try to justify his [ __ ] illness or
anything like that well it might have
been well the weird thing about him was
that after he got caught he pretty much
like confessed everything but then like
later on he was like nah didn't do
anything and then he tried to blame it
on his like roommates
yeah even like you know what the weird
thing is I was watching this documentary
about him today and it's like they were
talking to this one guy I don't know if
it was like his lawyer or whatever and
he's like John Wayne Gacy it was like
the day of his execution and it was like
an hour before he was gonna be executed
and he's talking to this guy on the
phone and he's got like all this stuff
like oh I need all this stuff for my
appeal and stuff like that and he's like
what can you call me back like later
today and the lawyers like dude you're
gonna be dead later today it's like what
are you talking I was kind of like that
guy who was being executed he's mentally
deficient didn't executed he gave me his
last meal he was telling you about that
gave his last meal and he ordered and it
was just like simple [ __ ] like hot dogs
and some pizza you know and and then he
had like some ice cream or a piece of
pie it was a piece of pie and he didn't
finish the pie and then and they said
and they said you know your pie he goes
no I'll eat that after I'll eat that
after the execution that's so sad though
because that kid probably didn't know
it's like I don't I don't think they
should be X he was killing kids he was
killing children I know but it's like
you know primer crackling I mean Joe
John Wayne Gacy is a different case cuz
yeah that dude was not mentally
deficient he was normal and he was just
[ __ ] I just I I think that he was so
deluded that he actually thought he was
gonna get out of it yeah that's what I
think yeah I mean he wasn't like
mentally [ __ ] or anything like that
no he had a he had a little bit higher
than average IQ yeah he's fine so it's
like I think just the fact that he said
that I think that he was cocky enough to
think that he was gonna get out of it
like at the last minute that's what I
think but yeah so he comes back to
Chicago and even though he hadn't
graduated high school as I said he
actually they let him enroll in a
business college northwestern business
college and he graduated from there in
1963 now apparently he did really well
here he was like everybody that knew him
said he was like a natural-born salesman
you know he's very though that's the
weird thing about him is he's very
personable he's very friendly he doesn't
come across as weird at all like they
talked to a lot of people that had no
him back 'native works with him or where
his neighbors or whatever and they all
said the same thing they were like
shocked when he was caught later on
because they're like he just seemed so
friendly he just seemed so open and it's
like there was nothing creepy about him
there was nothing not himself kind of
like the old-school Chicago gangsters
that whenever whenever you walk in just
kind of like a chucklehead yeah you mr.
Guido because he was polish Polish
polish / in German yeah yeah not as
alien he was like a chucklehead yeah you
wouldn't think that he was you know yeah
he was just like a regular guy like
everything and he was like all up in the
charities and he was all like a part big
part of the community and [ __ ] like that
it was shadow he was trying to put on an
aura of being a real man which
apparently it worked because nobody
suspected a thing so he starts working
for this this shoe company and he gets
promoted to salesman and he actually did
really well there and got promoted to
manager now also in 1963 he got engaged
to a co-worker of his whose name was
Marilyn Myers so they got married in
September of 1964 now Marilyn's family
was actually quite wealthy they managed
a whole bunch of KFC's so what ended up
happening there was that his JC's
father-in-law was like hey why don't you
guys come out to Waterloo Iowa Iowa and
you know Gacy can manage like three KFC
restaurants that he had out there
because you know he'd done so well at
the shoe store and everything like that
so Gacy and his new wife they move out
to Iowa and he starts managing KFC
restaurants and then later like they
moved into her parents house like her
parents had moved somewhere else and so
the parents like gave them a house so
they like had quite a bit of money like
it's like I said his wife's family had a
quite a bit of money they had like they
were big and like they had a bunch of
KFC franchises gel like that so that
happened in 1966
now Gacy was going to be
making over $100,000 a year like
managing these 30 like 115,000 hundred
and twenty thousand something like that
like that's a lot of [ __ ] money so he
was gonna be making that every year like
managing these three restaurants plus he
would get a share of the profits
so you know so he at this stage to like
I said he gets very involved in the
community um he got into the Jaycees
which is kind of like what what is that
even didn't that like [ __ ] what what
is the JC's JC's kind of like the
Shriners yeah it's like I mean I know
what it is okay you don't know what it
really is it's an organization of fat
dudes that [ __ ] don't have anything
to do they all get together try to saw
some kind of problems and you know what
I mean here on the damn community they
always did a haunted house every year
because I worked under a couple of
demands Club but I was like what the
hell are they even did it's a men's club
of [ __ ] middle age do you know
middle-aged guys like my age trying to
find some [ __ ] to do yeah one of the
things I like the Shriners used to do is
[ __ ] funny man they showed that they
took the parade's and the damn they're
little with this isn't everybody and
these riders and they'd be right in
those little photos from a little tiny
cars this little tiny fan is [ __ ]
hilarious man big respect and respect do
you know it's funny it's like problems a
little go-kart and look like probably
that's the only thing that people know
about the short that's surely the only
thing I know about the Shriners nowadays
is the Fez is throwing to look like any
old kind of you know like Ferraris or
whatever yeah yeah remember that [ __ ]
yeah so yeah so like I said gay sees way
up in the Jaycees he gets promoted to
like vice-president at one point
everyone thought he was super awesome
because he managed three KFC restaurants
that he'd bring like free Fried Chicken
to every event which you know that's
gonna make you a popular dude which is
it's funny because my uncle used to own
a bunch of KFC franchises when I was a
kid so it's like every time we had a
family get you in my book my parents
like worked in KFC in his cave c-store
as I was growing up
so it's like every family get-together
we always have like huge like buckets of
chicken so you know yeah so I'll tell
you what bad what I think I'm thinking I
can't see ahead in a while this thing
about we've been eating those rotisserie
chickens but it's really good we got you
we got a grocery store here named Publix
you can go down there and get a
rotisserie chicken like five different
flavors a whole [ __ ] chicken for like
four dollars yeah there's only like four
five four bucks for a whole chicken that
put KFC right out of [ __ ] right out
of the running
they had fried chicken too it's too
salty there it does well it depends on
what day you go and who's working that
day because I've gotten Fried Chicken I
don't get fried check in there a lot
because usually if I'm going to Publix
deli I'm usually good for sub but it's
like I've got Fried Chicken there enough
times that about 70% of the time it's
too salty yeah it's too salty yeah I
don't think if she's doing as good as it
used to where there isn't one around
here I haven't eaten there there's one
not too far from here I haven't eaten
there in a really long time I wait I ate
there a lot as a kid it's greasy like I
can only maybe eat one piece maybe two
but that I like the engine yeah I like
the original see I only like the crispy
I think I can use original too there's
too much batter on it yeah but it's so
good it's like all crunchy inches we got
a Popeyes up the street we haven't been
hit neither they got that red they just
built that [ __ ] and they got that red
beans and rice that's them let me tell
you so I kept forgetting there's a pop
but they just built a Popeyes like a
month ago like right up the street from
her let me tell you a vignette and he
tell you people something this isn't
ominous to you on a global level cuz we
got people looking in England we got
people even even in a micro niche or
Indonesia listening to this show I'm I'm
Southern Mississippi in a camp in
Louisiana also and Mississippi Popeyes
is where you go that's real Popeyes
that's real southern chicken really and
you and the and they have the best red
beans and rice in the world
they do I would have got red beans and
rice every time I go there I always get
a shrimp po-boy shrimp po-boy to rest
best but yeah we gotta go hit that up
there didn't they they got that new
sandwich public man so think we're
plugin plugin for [ __ ] pop bit of
Popeyes like forever
there you see there used to be one by my
apartment but I lived over near Oviedo
like I used to work in OB no yeah and
there was a Popeye's on the way so every
now and then like I'm going to colonize
the next couple days maybe go tomorrow
but yeah they just built one like right
by our house and we haven't been to it
yet I just keep forgetting that it's up
there because it hasn't been there that
long
Popeyes I think is better than kasi I
mean I haven't had KFC it didn't used to
be yeah KFC was good when I was a kid ya
can't use me it was greasy but it was
good it's gone downhill from what I
heard I remember it's funny because I
remember when I had no best gravy they
did and the best coleslaw yeah I would
agree with that yeah I'm not a huge
coleslaw fan but yeah but I remember
when I was a little kid cuz like I said
my dad used to manage one so I used to
go in the back and him and his friend
Perry used to be back there like making
the big old tubs and mashed potatoes and
stuff like I ever met and I used to be
like be fascinated by this big [ __ ]
thing that had the like the big stir
because it was like you know how you
have the thing where you know you make
the you know frosting or [ __ ] like that
and it's like this little mixer or
whatever but they had like what a big
huge one it was like the big huge
[ __ ] tub and then it bit stir and
they would always make them like mashed
potatoes in there tell you foreigners
and I [ __ ] love mash I'm gonna tell
you foreigners over there some
especially people of there in the UK
because we have somebody you can you we
got her we got UK page burners for our
UK a true American could eat more
chicken than a human has ever seen I
don't know it's Americans AMERICA
AMERICA AMERICA makes more [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah what do you sing the day in America
makes more chicken in a month
okay then Europe makes in 10 years I'm
sure where are some chicken breeding
[ __ ] I'll tell you that
chickens everywhere chickens [ __ ]
everywhere we can eat just so much
chickens it's it chickens like [ __ ]
was 60 cents a pound sometimes yeah it's
really it's cheap woman you can do a lot
with it yeah and like we got our own
company called Sanderson farms it's at
Mississippi yeah that's right
they said Sanderson farms since the
[ __ ] chicken to Russia and Russia
kick that [ __ ] back they said no way can
a chicken be that size there's something
wrong they're kind of like Frank and
chick they're like Frankie chickens of
centers and Farms chicken breast is six
times the size of a mortal chicken
breast I mean I'm even a little bit kind
of avocados are like well we go to Sam's
and we go buy the like [ __ ] that's more
into size cuz I like dark meat but it's
like we get like chicken breasts and
they are like freakishly long yeah the
one I'm like okay I'm a little
uncomfortable yeah the ones that are the
ones that the ones that Sam's Club or
it's Sam's that's Sanderson farms
I mean we've we've made dishes with one
chicken Brad that fed like two or three
people yeah and the grains and the meat
are too big
it's tough weird so it's a tough it pops
and crunch it's weird texture and I've
Harika chicken I've heard that Santa's
farms can't take a chicken from a
hatchling to a full-grown chicken in ten
days I believe it so maybe not 10 days
but I believe it that's just what I
think they said 10 days it's how many
Mormons but yeah it's gotta be it's
something wrong they're still delicious
the legs are good but I'm very
suspicious
evidently they break their legs just
walking around because they because
there's so much and the chickens so
young I've heard the dead ones with
turkeys also like at Thanksgiving too
they're so young that their bones
haven't hardened because they're growing
at such a [ __ ] huge rate so evidently
they just put them in a damn box so they
can't walk anywhere for real they need
to just like make meat in Petri dishes
eventually they will then we can all
feel better about it yeah they'll just
[ __ ] clone that damn chicken breast
over we don't have to kill no animal
like you know the feet I mean it'll take
yeah it was like you know it's a win-win
you'll taste the same it's like
chemically and yeah and then you're
anatomically you're doing it in a dab
laboratory slash factory where it's all
condensed all in one little spot like
you know that's why those yes why finish
you know I heard that those are actually
grown in a damn barrel full of water
like a 55-gallon oil drum full of water
and that they doped those things up and
they live their whole lives in that damn
barrel and there's evidently just fish
just a little bit of water in there yeah
and they're blowing air through it
bubbles you know and that they have to
put bunch of damn valium and stuff into
the damn water to keep him sedated and
they grow quickly too
you think they would eat it I don't know
I'm just saying that's what I heard
they say it's like real inhumane the way
they're growing those fish in that damn
barrel well yeah kind of every like
factory farmed yeah but that you know
but we're eating it I know yeah but
everything they never see any light or
anything like I said I can't wait so
weird [ __ ] gross and [ __ ] meet in the
lab they'll believe that [ __ ] they'll
grow it in a damn factory every taster
same I don't care we're off topic joking
off topic okay no 300 because I started
talking about KFC and then you went off
about Popeyes and let that goddamn
Popeyes everybody there we can go to
Papa okay all right let's go to Popeyes
tomorrow okay okay all right so as I
said like Gacy got like promoted to like
vice president of the JC's and
everything like that now his wife also
had two kids yes Gacy had children a son
named Michael was born in 1966 and they
also had a daughter named Christine who
was born in 1967 now apparently he
hadn't killed anybody yet okay so it's
like at this point it almost seemed like
he had like the idyllic perfect life he
had a really good job he had a lot of
money he had a wife he had two kids he
had like you know the perfect American
Dream blah-dee-blah
now what from what he said he
said that his dad came to visit him
during this period of his life which he
called quote unquote perfect and he said
his dad came to visit him and apologized
to him for all the [ __ ] that he had said
and done to him as a kid it's like okay
I guess you came you worked out okay you
know what I mean like you actually like
made something of yourself I don't know
if that's true or not or if that was
just like wishful thinking
because like I said that's all he wanted
was like approval from his dad so I
don't know if his dad actually ever did
that or not that doesn't seem like
something that someone like that would
do but I you know I don't know could be
wrong now it does seem though that there
was some even before he had killed
anyone there was some kind of like
creepy [ __ ] going on behind the scenes
apparently there was a lot of porn
prostitution a lot of drug use
wife-swapping
all that kind of stuff yeah so now
according to several sources Gacy
actually like frequented prostitutes so
he cheated on his wife a lot
he also supposedly like opened up this
little club in his basement where he
would let like a lot of his underage
friends and employees like come and
drink you know work bread they weren't
really supposed to and apparently
according to some of them later on he
also made sexual advances towards some
of these young men too so you know now
and if he got in trouble later he would
just say oh I was just kidding right you
know that's the last refuge of the
skinny I was just joking he's trying to
get some ass like you know legitimately
you know they're either underage but
yeah so was he charged really legitimate
it's just yeah yeah he was actually
trying to like ask for a neutron and
then they'd be like nah man what are you
doing he's like nah man I was just
kidding man I mean or I was just testing
you to see if you would do it yeah like
he would be a [ __ ]
yeah he would say [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah so what'd he do it yeah I
understand I understand his man oh man I
hate that [ __ ] I hate that [ __ ] like
yeah I understand I hate that [ __ ] when
somebody asks you some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you're like no man what the [ __ ] is I
was just kidding no no you weren't
kidding that's he's doing yeah
all right so let's actually take a break
right now cuz you're about at an hour
I'm this refresh this drink tonight yeah
I probably need another one to you this
probably is gonna go on three hours
Lukey because I'm not even like hardly
I'm just like right I told you don't let
me go on like that
well yeah but if I tell you to shut up
you get mad at me I can't win did you
see that like somebody on the YouTube
comments like on the last show that we
did about pandemics they said they
wondered if they if that I made you
sleep on the couch Oh Maxie it's [ __ ]
they don't understand what it's like
around here we're not well I don't want
to give the impression we're not always
fighting it is that kind of like just
that we know well he's just kind of like
always going on and I'm just like yeah
whatever nothing serious
we're just like [ __ ] with each other
we've known each other a long time yeah
so we get away with the last you a very
long time yeah so alright so we're gonna
take a break right now will you back
momentarily to talk more about [ __ ]
John Wayne Gacy hey guys I'll be back in
a minute
what's up Sweeney where you goin yeah
hey I know you're on TV
come on what huh
you're just looking for like non-edible
things that you can eat sure look it
look it
don't eat that please don't eat that oh
why do you do that why do you do that
why do you do that that can't feel good
look at her look at that I buy you all
these two sticks and yet and yet you
just keep doing that I know I I don't
know what you're dealing I don't know
you're dealing I know you can't help it
it's an addiction oh now you're gonna
chew that one all right damn you she's
getting all in that you know into it
hi-y boogie
it's part of her eternal quest to get
Pookie drool all over everything
ya know oh look what you did
you've nothing to smile on Tuesday guard
she just ate that right off of there not
a sentimentalist I take it yeah you sick
of that okay you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we're back we're back in we
got more drinks we found the cat I got
pork chops cookies we got pork chops
cooking yeah I got a timer set for an
hour well if the timer goes off we're
gonna have to turn it off and then come
back to it later it's my applewood rub
on there I'm gonna cook them and then
I'll turn it slightly you don't worry
about it I'm not gonna inform the
audience it'll just make them hungry our
shoes will make you fat because we're
just like what one of these days I know
we already have like four weekly shows
now but it's like remember back in the
old days when we were talking about
doing like a Food Show or like a retro
show we were talking about doing and we
never like got around to it because we
always entertain got a huge workload
yeah that might still be fun to do that
one of these days we don't get that much
traffic on those movie reviews that's
true I do feel like people like the
story is more than they like yeah yeah
we might maybe we'll just stop them well
the town's the matinee show I feel like
we don't get as much on the matinee show
like as the older the roof yeah the
retrospectives say we'll get we get
action on yeah yeah it's time but
they're gonna be like the older movies
yeah but I don't know people like well
cuz there's a lot of people reviewing
new movies so it's like right we just
started doing that because we got like
the AMC stuffs burgers like [ __ ] was
free so bonus
why do you blur my [ __ ] your blemishes
your blaring [ __ ] that mean okay let's
get back to the case all right so let's
get back to talking about John Wayne
Gacy so August of 1967 gentlemen DAC
committed what is thought to be his
first known sexual assault not a murder
his first known sexual assault on a
teenage boy now this was a 15 year old
named Donald Voorhees no relation to
Jason Morgan yeah he was actually which
is a fictional character in case you
didn't know um my childhood if I can
window it anymore
that's all right that's why I felt about
like the
the antagonist of My Bloody Valentine I
thought that miner was gonna commit
after I saw Friday 13th [ __ ] apart too
bad that was it I was [ __ ] scared of
that [ __ ] after I saw that he had his
mom's head out on the [ __ ] table with
the sweater on it and everything huh
yeah so much stuff yeah one of these
days we'll have to do what have to do
like we'll have to pull a cinemassacre
and do like a whole the whole Friday the
13th yeah
review see was watching that when I was
[ __ ] visiting my dad out in
Mississippi during the summers sesh it
was country so [ __ ] yeah Jason live
it out there [ __ ] right yeah he lives
out in the [ __ ] camp he's gonna let
us in your window yeah if you live it up
in London Hey well London you don't give
a [ __ ] about [ __ ] Jason and you know
you [ __ ] know man Mississippi yeah
could be around any [ __ ] quarter well
the thing about it though is that in the
early days Jason could only like if you
went to if you were dumb enough to like
go to Camp Crystal Lake then you were
gonna get your ass killed but it's like
Jason wasn't gonna go like out into the
world and tell people that were out
there until like Jason Takes Manhattan
and Jason goes to space and all that
other we had a good Camp Crystal Lake
though all that tight ass and the whole
focus shorts and [ __ ] you were gonna go
with you [ __ ] tight ass is insurance
everywhere you don't go to that specific
place do you like a [ __ ] 14 15 year
old boy you're gonna watch Friday 13th
that's just all there is to it I know I
ain't taking her clothes off and that's
it
I know yeah it look good well you know I
was into it but it's like you know what
I don't think about it too much
let's get back we were getting
sidetracked again yeah yes how I said
well because I said boys that's why okay
so this this fifteen-year-old was
actually the son of someone that was
also in the Jaycees with John Wayne Gacy
so apparently what ended up happening
and this was something that Gacy would
do a lot he like he would get the kids
to come to his house by saying hey I
have some really good porn this was 1967
you guys it's not like nowadays were
important ubiquitous and you could just
see it every time you opened your might
have been technically illegal in 67 it
might have been
because there's a bunch of inter state
laws about transporting it across laws
which kept his suppressed abode it was
like something clubs did man that's
funny it's weird because because I went
to a couple years ago I went to New York
and they have a Museum of Sex there and
I went to that and they had like a whole
like exhibition about like blue movies
like back in the 20s and 30s and stuff
like that so it's like they had a bunch
of that stuff showing and it's like
interesting how because now it's like
[ __ ] ubiquitous like porn is
everywhere like you really have to kind
of sort of actively avoid it because
it's kind of all over the place
but it's like back in the old days you
had to like go to specific places to see
it yeah like the even theaters wouldn't
show it it was just like kind of on
these little like kind of homemade movie
things and they kind of like made the
rounds one was for [ __ ] Kings
actually up until they pretty much yeah
it's like totally weird would have worn
it on the bottom the papyrus yeah it was
so hard corpus pan [ __ ] pants or
satyrs having sex with goats and [ __ ]
that's their [ __ ] part yeah like that
famous statue that they won't put out
and yeah you know that was a nice statue
of nobles that uncovered that they had a
big event was there it saw what it was
it was a satyr heaven like I got shot
[ __ ] yeah shut it down didn't happen
bestiality we had to that is that was
kind of like well it wasn't really
bestiality it was like because it wasn't
a human that was doing it it was a god
or demigod having sex with an animal
satyr still kind of yeah as weird she's
kind of but it's a nice statue though
yeah it's just obviously car craft it is
it's beautiful and it's like that's
what's so funny about it it's like they
won't [ __ ] it has something to do with
some kind of Roman story I think it is
yeah yeah it's just funny to me that
they won't like put it on public display
because they think everyone's gonna be
like [ __ ] scandalous I'm like it
these days I don't think so but yeah so
that's kinda
how Casey would like lure some of his
earlier victims like back he's like hey
I've got porn and like 15 year old boy
that are like okay I'm there
so yes sadly so this 15 year old boy
whose dad like also worked for the
Jaycees which in a way like Casey's kind
of like a dummy because he's going after
kids of like dudes he knows ya better
like coworkers and like oh that's pretty
stupid yeah but yeah well with little
head yeah well yeah that's kind of wrong
so he gets the kid over there like
saying he's got porn then he starts
giving the kid a bunch of liquor which
you know the kids like okay he's 15 you
know what I mean and then he forces the
kid to give him head wrong you know for
perform oral sex if you want to be like
like all proper about it now apparently
other kids were went through the same
[ __ ] like over the next couple of months
like Casey was doing the same kind of
[ __ ] um another er that tactic that Gacy
would use I love this this was a sixty
ZL he would say that he was and keep in
mind these are like 14 15 year old kids
okay I don't judge too harshly he would
say that he was doing scientific
experiments into like homosexual
behavior right and he wanted it yeah and
he wanted to research it he's like I'll
give you $50 if you suck my dick or let
me suck your dick that's Oh kind of low
level oh [ __ ] but like I said this is
the 60s and these are kids yeah so you
know he was hired by the government I
think that caution when he was implying
he was hired by the government to get
down on the bottom of it right well
because in a lot of places it was
illegal Edison so yeah [ __ ] so
this happens to Dahl Voorhees now
eventually Donald tells his dad about
what happened to him and his dad
reported it to the police
yeah so Gacy gets arrested and charged
with sodomy now he had also attempted
assault on a 16 year old
boy named Edward Lynch now when they
brought Gacy into custody he totally was
like no man I didn't do any of that
stuff give me a polygraph blah blah so
they give him a polygraph but it's kind
of inconclusive and like when they asked
him about the crimes that he's accused
of he seems like really nervous about it
so you know that was something there now
he says and this is kind of like a
trademark of some [ __ ] that Gacy would
do he says that I think that Voorhees
his dad accused me of that stuff
because he didn't want me to be
vice-president at the JC's or whatever
the [ __ ] position was it was he
basically said oh it's political that's
what he said and he's like and that's
why I like people are making up all this
stuff about me now the the creepy thing
about this though was that so many
people in the Jaycees like knew him and
were like friends of his and stuff that
they believed that [ __ ] so it's like
they were like back to well they didn't
know I mean you know what I mean they
didn't know any better so like they
pretty much defended him because of like
you know whatever is some dude it's just
like [ __ ] making [ __ ] up about him
because they don't want to do guys
president whatever so 1968 late summer
of 1968 um I can gaze like not the
brightest bulb on the tree is all I'm
saying
so he pays one of his employees who was
18 years old and his name was Russell
Schroder
he pays this guy to go beat up Don
Voorhees to like keep him from
testifying against him is this a good
idea it is not that could backfire yeah
you think yeah yeah so he basically says
he's like okay well you take Donald to
like a secluded spot you sprayed him
with mace and then like beat his ass so
yeah he said I will he he promised this
dude like $300 I don't think he paid him
upfront but he said if you do it I'll
give you $300
the kid the kid does it it's like he
lures Donald to like a park he sprays
the kid doll Voorhees with mace and then
he beats him up and he's like telling
him the whole time it's like you know
don't testify kids [ __ ] Gacy at the
trial right yeah so Voorhees gets away
he goes to the cops and reports it as
you would um and he recognized the dude
that had attacked him because he knew
that guy right so he said hey it was
rush record so he mighta look into that
so this runs like a [ __ ] black
special-forces I did this [ __ ]
this is like not yeah this is all you
ever know so yes so Russell gets
arrested like literally the next day so
he's like initially he's just like no I
didn't do that [ __ ] but then like they
keep questioning him and finally he's
like okay well John Wayne Gacy paid me
to do this [ __ ] so Casey gets arrested
and he gets you know not only did he
have sodomy charges but now he has the
charge of like pink this other kid to go
and beat this other kids ass for [ __ ]
whatever so at this point they're like
okay well this guy's clearly not right
in the head so they order him to undergo
a psychiatric evaluation at the State
University of Iowa now two doctors
evaluate John Wayne Gacy and they
conclude that he has an antisocial
personality disorder which no that's
close yeah and they promised they'd
recommend there's a like look I don't
think this they're like okay he is
definitely going to reoffended this back
in the 60s he's gonna reoffending I
don't think that he will get anything
out of any therapy or medical treatment
or anything like this so they're
basically not in so many words but
they're basically saying you should
this dude up because this is not good
and it will probably get worse later on
there right yeah so one of the there was
a report which you know was one of his
psychiatric evaluations in 1968 one of
the quotes from that was the most
striking aspect of the test results is
the patient's total denial of
responsibility for everything that has
happened to him
he can produce an alibi for everything
he presents himself as a victim of
circumstances and blames other people
who are out to get him
right the patient attempts to assure a
sympathetic response by depicting
himself as being at the mercy of a
hostile environment okay so basically
they arrest him he's oh it wasn't me
yeah it was always like it was a
political motivation it was now what
ended up happening so jay-z standing
trial for the sodomy charge and also the
charge of like hiring the other kid to
beat the other kids as for testifying or
whatever so his attorney tells them okay
well enter a plea of guilty because
apparently there was just like one count
of sodomy because like I said that was
illegal at the time he pleaded not
guilty to the other charges however now
he said and this this is kind of a
lifelong thing with Gacy he says that
yes him and Donald Voorhees had sex but
that it was consensual and he also said
was underage he offered well yeah he
said it was like he offered no way and I
was curious that's what he said he's
curious right yeah I was curious
that's what he the reason why the reason
why he's saying it was consensual of
course because the charges were a lot
less yeah cuz back in those days tucking
you I don't think you get a lot of you
could I don't think you can get a lot of
trouble for having sex in somebody was
underage probably not that doesn't seem
like the 70s was fair actually what how
old was he what 16 15 wait who Casey no
no the victim 15 yeah I don't
I think the age of consent
States back in those days would have
been more like about 16 the legal age of
consent yeah still I don't think they
had to [ __ ] give giving him a couple
months so I yeah I feel like it was in
the 60s and 70s early would not have
seen that as a big deal
yet it been like which is kind of
terrifying because we know how that [ __ ]
goes uh yeah you know back in those days
you know people were getting I mean well
look at it this way fifty years before
that people get married at 13 yeah but
like I could like I can see like the not
creepiness because I'm very into them we
might have discussed this before but I'm
I'm like kind of a thing where if you're
like boyfriend is 17 and you're 15 or
something like that it is like that
that's a different issue now if if
someone is 14 or 15 and the dude is like
30 yeah that's that she all set to
remember the thinking of the time I
remember when I was young I guess you
could say the purity of a boy didn't
mean [ __ ] it was only the girls well I
don't drink anyone yeah well I don't
think anyone nowadays still cares about
purity of boy I don't I don't ever hear
about that well they did they did
convict that one teacher of having sex
with you know like kid he was probably
about well 14 which which rightfully so
because like anytime you take advantage
you're doing that's underage
yeah they're doing it I don't care what
go on after now but back in the back of
the 60s they wouldn't give a [ __ ] no
they wouldn't have
oh you had fun didn't you kid that's
what I mean and I and there's still some
lingering [ __ ] of that but I do feel
like they're at least getting to a point
where that's recognized as like hey
that's not good because like I said I
don't care what gender you are if you're
[ __ ] thirty thirty-five years old and
you're going after a [ __ ]
fourteen-year-old kid yeah yeah that's
not good yeah I don't care if you're a
man or a woman or whatever
I really don't so yeah so nobody bought
KC's story about yeah it was consensual
and I was just like experimenting
because he offered it or whatever so he
gets convicted of sodomy in December of
1968 he gets sentenced to ten years
which I mean that's a heavy well that's
what I mean like in light of his later
crimes it doesn't seem like that big a
deal but it's like just he only got
convicted of sodomy yeah which it wasn't
even like rape it wasn't even anything
yeah ten years seems like a lot
that's a heavy sentence for that engine
not for him I'm just saying in general
not a heavy sentence for the crime right
but for that charge in general that was
that just means being gay sodomy means
be that's what I mean can you imagine
getting ten years just for like having
sex with someone and like I said even if
it was consensual even if they believed
that it was consensual even if it was
two adults that yeah it was consensual
that's not saying they didn't normally
didn't do that though holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
they normally didn't do that though my
understanding was usually it was just a
slap on the wrist
goddamn yeah but I know this wasn't that
long I think what they do is so backward
I think what they were doing was is that
they understood what they were dealing
with they were dealing with some kind of
serial child child molester maybe not
they say they're going like max that
[ __ ] out because they because we'll see
how this at listen somebody max this ass
out they knew what they were dealing
with yeah but somebody asked me but let
him out because in those days you could
get out of long sentences in other ways
too true I mean [ __ ] if I could Macduff
got the death sentence got that
community life and then Texas did all
kinds of weird [ __ ] and he got out six
years later and after [ __ ] raping he
killed six six seven years later
something I after kill but now I might
being a little bit more but it wasn't
long after a [ __ ] murder in a teenage
girl yeah it's weird and so it just
seems like I mean I know because
situation it depends on the county a
defense with the city it just it depends
on the person like it depends on the
person on the bench it depends on the
person people on the jury system is that
it's like well you're not gonna get
consistency because it's human
you know his humans like you know doing
it all so politics and needs of the
state yes so it's like sometimes like
somebody that did a horriffic crime was
oh they're out in 18 months and then
like another dude that did something
like nothing and then they're like in
there one away for [ __ ] 20 years it's
like [ __ ] up has to do it Imani
like well that too if you're poor like I
said and I've said this on the show
before if you're poor you're just hosed
well that's not what I was supposed
McDuck got Macduff got out of all that
[ __ ] it out of a death sentence and
walked in a few years in Texas because
the Texas economy back in those days was
[ __ ] collapse and they couldn't keep
all those guys [ __ ] locked up yeah
yeah I mean he had a death sentence but
then they had a governor or some [ __ ]
went down where they declared that to be
unconstitutional
so they got life instead but then there
was some other weird [ __ ] that happened
that said well we see the 25 to life and
then there's somehow he got 25 and then
you did 25 but you only had to do half
of that the rest of it you could do it
on parole and then there was good time a
good behavior and [ __ ] and it was and
they were doing all that kind of crap
because they didn't have money to keep
all these guys locked up well yeah you
know Texas at that time was having a big
influx of guys suck and committing
crimes and then their economy sucked and
they had to let these some of them go
and then they let McDuff out that
[ __ ] was a vicious [ __ ]
serial killer yeah the legs like the
only kind I think there's only one they
let go in the history of the u.s. that
they let a serial killer go and they
news the Sara killer yeah that's you
know what anybody go what some [ __ ]
pot smokers go they were letting em go
too you know it was a it was a mm burn
it was a text rapist it was a Texas is
that kind of the same thing it was a
Texas thing that was happening in the
early 80s it's just you know it's it's
messed up well like I said it's in this
situation it's like yeah he probably
shouldn't have been let out but it's
like in the 70s they didn't really I
don't know it's just it just seems like
a really weird situation so he gets 10
years now he gets convicted on the day
he's convicted understandably his wife
is yeah like [ __ ] you I'm out she filed
for divorce and took his children away
he never saw either his ex-wife or his
children ever again and probably to
their benefit he's ready to give a [ __ ]
anyway I don't think he did I think nice
[ __ ] smokescreen that was his beard
yeah I I have read some quotes where he
was just kind of like he didn't want
custody of the kids or he didn't really
care if he saw them again because he
didn't really I mean you know he doesn't
really seem like it he was into those
boys model citizen so he gets imprisoned
at an amorous Anamosa State Penitentiary
um a model prisoner at this [ __ ]
penitentiary he got to the position of
head cook at this place and he I guess
in the prison they also had the JC's in
there and he kind of rose up in the
ranks in there and he got like all these
people to join and [ __ ] like that he got
like a miniature golf course and the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and everything now of
course in prison in a person here yeah
so it's like he's kind of like one of
those dudes it's like he's always just
kind of like trying to get some [ __ ]
goin man like [ __ ] Jesus Christ so he
applied for parole in June of 1969 this
was denied while he was in there he
apparently finished high school finally
he got his diploma in November of 1969
cuz like I said before he had never
finished high school now Christmas Day
of 1969 Casey's dad died from cirrhosis
cuz like I said he was an alcoholic and
apparently Gacy was really really upset
about this because he wanted to he
petition to like the the prison you know
supervisors to let him go to the funeral
and they would not let him go and
apparently all the other prisoners that
were serving time with him and stuff
like that said that he was really really
broken up about he was very upset that
he had not got a chance to say goodbye
to his father or like had never had like
a chance to like get like final
acceptance from his dad or whatever so
that was apparently something that like
really really bothered him so he gets
parole and he gets probation in 1970 in
summer of 1970 he had only served if
you're counting 18 months of the 10-year
sentence although like I said 10-year
sentence for just sodomy
even though it was an underage kid this
is the six days that we're talking about
so it's like nowadays
ya know one be surprised by that but
back then it seems like that was kind of
an excessive but he still got out after
18 months that's why they gave it to me
cuz I figured he would be out in 18
months 18 months is nothing
it yeah you're happy yeah a 10-year
prison terms that's nothing and they
basically said well we'll let you out as
long as you go back to Chicago and live
with your mother you can't be out past
10:00 p.m. and he had to go to the Iowa
parole board to update them on his
progress
so Gacy goes back to Chicago to live
with his mom and he gets a job as a
short-order cook in her restaurant now
he didn't last you long before he did
some more [ __ ] because in February of
1971 he sexually assaulted
yet another young boy so this restaurant
well yeah well what happened was so the
kid said that Gacy had basically lured
him into his car like it was at the
Chicago Greyhound bus terminal it's like
I think that he just offered me he's
like hey I've got marijuana and the kid
was like oh okay whatever so the kid
gets in the car and then Gacy tries to
like force him into sex now the kid
reported it to police as you would
however because the kid would not show
up in court when the court Tate arrived
the charges were dismissed so um so that
didn't like turn up on his because he
was still on parole at this point Casey
was so it didn't like turn up on the
whole like parole thing because normally
that would slay me right back in jail if
he did some [ __ ] like that but because
the kid didn't show up in jail it I
guess it didn't like go through or
whatever so they didn't like find out
about it Casey's mom gives him some
money
he buys a house in Cook County Illinois
now this house at eight to one three
west some
Avenue is the house that is most
associated with John Wayne Gacy and all
his crimes because that's where he
buried most of the people that he killed
so yeah so he moves into the house at
this stage he becomes engaged to yet
another woman how can these dudes keep
finding people to marry them I don't
understand it's like in those days I
want ads
personals um yeah I I think that well I
think that this woman Carol Hoff this
was someone that he had known back in
high school and I think they dated back
in high school like not that seriously
but then they kind of like reconnected
later on it she had been married and she
subsequently she had a kid or two like
in the meantime because she'd been
married and yeah so she she was divorced
in several so they kind of like
reconnected like after a long time so
they kind of got back together at this
stage now she moves into his house with
her children she had two daughters now
the mom his mom was actually like moving
there
like living there too but she moved out
in 1972
now one week before
Gacy married Carol Hoff he got arrested
again and he was charged this time with
aggravated battery and reckless conduct
now this was someone named Jackie Dee
said that Gacy had been posing as a
police officer like had showed him a
sheriff's badge had lured him into his
cop car or he had a car that sort of
looked like a cop car like he had kind
of like the spotlight and it shone like
that like he did that on purpose so he
lured him into the car and like made him
give him a [ __ ] damn like a cop does
yes well some cops do Jeff thank you
heard about that yes well I'm you know
I'm a girl like I said I used to work at
night nice to drive at home alone all
this
and it's like I would not pull over for
a cop no [ __ ] way okay I've heard all
kind of terrible things not all cops are
bad obviously most of them are fine but
it's like there's always how you gonna
do with that you just you have to go
somewhere where there's other people
okay and like I said there's even if
there's even a protocol where you can
like [ __ ] call like especially if
you're a woman like driving on your own
you need to like call like the [ __ ]
police station near town or whatever and
tell them look there's a cop following
me but I don't want to pull over because
I don't know if it's a real cop or if
it's a rogue cop who's gonna rape me or
whatever so it's like I'm going
somewhere where there's like a whole
bunch of people like a whole bunch of
witnesses yeah and that's what you have
to do because I've got pulled over a
couple times when I was coming home from
work like and like it 2 or 3 in the
morning yeah and it's like I had to pull
in front of like the 24/7 [ __ ]
convenience store where people were in
there just in case because I've had
[ __ ] I had a cop pulled me over at
3:30 in the morning and he said that my
that the light over my license plate
license plate was out yeah and it wasn't
what he made that up yep saw you wanted
to talk to you yep ok
so I'm glad that I pulled into a 24/7
convenience store where there were
people because that was the story that
he gave me oh the light over your
license plate is out and then like I
looked later I'm like yeah no it's not
ok [ __ ] off seriously so so yeah so
these these charges yeah what oh that's
all that's all you're telling
all right you're like the king of the
game yeah
just playing the game so apparently
these charges later got dropped because
the the guy that was the Jackie D the
guy that was like bringing the charges
apparently attempted to blackmail John
Wayne Gacy like he was gonna give him
money and like say he was gonna drop her
so there was like this big thing so
those charges got dropped now so at this
point
Gacy marries his you know girlfriend
Carol Hoff and her - not her and her two
daughters move into Casey's house his
infamous summer now Avenue house now
Gacy by this time had quit his job he
had been a shorter cook and he started
his own construction business which he
called painting decorating and
maintenance or PBM contractors so this
was like kind of like doing like minor
kind of [ __ ] they would like paint signs
it was like fixed little [ __ ] or anyhow
or whatever now later on like the
business would kind of grow a bit bigger
and he would do like interior design and
whatnot now by 1978 apparently the
business was making quite a bit of money
two hundred thousand dollars a year like
in I guess in those days money which
that's all that's a lot of money that's
a lot of money now it is but like in
1978 that was like an even more money
that was like happen that's more like
half a million or a million dollars like
nowadays so one thing that Gacy would do
though is that once he started this
contracting company in order to
ostensibly keep down costs he would hire
like high school kids yeah high school
boys yeah well in like tight booty yeah
like he would pay them twice the going
rate so it was very like attractive like
for teenage boys who like were just in
high school and attractive for the
teenage boys it was attractive for JA
yeah clearly yeah of course
so 1973 he takes one of hit one of
these teenage employees to Florida to
like go check out a property and
apparently Gacy raped this youth in the
hotel room so apparently this kid was
like not some would not stay in the
hotel room and went out and slept on the
[ __ ] beach in Florida like you do
yeah so yes so apparently so they get
back to Chicago and the kid drives to
gay C's house and like tries to beat
Casey's ass
yeah again as you would and Jacey's his
wife's mom like came and like tried like
she didn't know it was going on so she
tried to like she thought this was just
some and so she tried to like drive him
away and Gacy tried to like kind of say
that it's like oh well he worked for me
and I didn't he thought that I didn't
pay him enough and that's why he was
trying to beat me up nothing he had like
try to rape him and stuff or whatever so
like I said Gacy at this point it's like
this is 1974 he's trying to become it it
almost seems like he's trying to become
like he wants to become accepted by the
community he's very active in the
Jaycees he's very action like charity
drives like I said he starts dressing up
as a clown like Pogo and patches like he
has the whole like all the clown stuff
he goes in like entertains at children's
hospitals he gets involved in politics
you know he he does all this kind of
stuff where it just seems like he's
desperately trying to win approval from
the community I guess because he
couldn't get it from his dad
which is sad enough but it seems like
that was kind of the whole focus of his
life was he was trying to get acceptance
from people and in a way it seems to
have worked because I mean everyone in
the community just seemed to think he
was a great guy right like I said they
didn't really know like anything of it
so he gets um he gets all up in like the
Democratic Party in Chicago
he gets he's on like the street lighting
committee which doesn't sound like it's
really that big of a deal but you know
he was excited about it I guess he also
got up to the title of precinct captain
he got appointed the director the
director of Chicago's polish
Constitution Day Parade which in Chicago
was a big deal because there's a lot of
Polish immigrants for his grandparents
were polish German immigrants also so he
was very active in the Polish community
so he kind of gets to be in the parade
and everything like that
during this parade very famously he was
photographed with then first lady
Rosalynn Carter that was in 1970 he's on
the Polish parade he's probably got like
a big old he carried a big old flag or a
big old statue of daddy is Cusco daddy's
daddy's Cusco [ __ ] statue and [ __ ]
yeah oh and number one Thaddeus is an
awesome man I like that yeah so like I
said he's on like he's kind of a big
deal like a bit like you know not super
famous or anything but everybody in the
Chicago community kind of knows who he
is because he's kind of like up on them
you know all in the community so
apparently in 1975 Gacy informs his wife
that he has that he is bisexual now
apparently this is what I've heard he
has sex with his wife on Mother's Day
and then he tells her that's the last
time we're having sex what you have the
right to do that you can just kind of
let go this is the last time we're gonna
be married but this is like well I guess
you have the right to do that
but this is gonna work out this is this
is how this is gonna work out it's kind
of one of those things where it's like
it's not like against the law but like I
can't understand what a man is thinking
this you could be like oh by the way
this is the last time we're having sex
we're not gonna have sex anymore
yeah did he tell her she can do what
everything she wants I bet not I don't
know like I don't know but
knowing this type of dude I would assume
not now she's got it remain boy because
you know how dudes are they're just like
well you can't have sex with any but but
I can that's kind of how dudes do
general do the job doesn't that'll be
their thing where it's just like well
you know you can't because you're like a
filthy house say I'm reasonable though
you know honest you aren't that you know
that a woman is a mortal woman look you
stay here I'm gonna go [ __ ] get me
some ass yeah you just stay here and
don't do any I'm gonna go out and bang
everyone that moves but you're not
allowed yeah you want out kids yeah
that's kind of what I feel like well
that's kind of what I feel like these
type of dudes that's where they're
coming from that's your way they can do
it yeah but you're not allowed to your
role in life because I feel like they
don't it like we were talking about the
[ __ ] essay and show like that before I
don't think they see women as fully
human yeah they're the same way they're
like [ __ ] they're like [ __ ]
chattel yeah it almost seems like you're
just loving it yeah you stay here yeah
yeah I'm gonna go out and just do
whatever so yeah so he apparently
informed his wife of this and then
started like you know going out most
evenings and not coming home gee wonder
where he was he told his wife he'd been
working late now his wife apparently saw
Gacy hanging out with a lot of teenage
boys also she began to found a find a
bunch of like gay porn around the house
which she was kind of upset about
apparently the wife also found men's
wallets driver's licenses that kind of
stuff started to get a little suspicious
but this is your husband so I don't
think that's immediately will you jump
to like my husband's a serial killer you
know I mean especially not back then so
I guess she thought it was weird but she
didn't like really do much about it so I
mean she did actually kind of get up in
his face and be like hey what the [ __ ]
is all this stuff and he just said
oh well that's not here so you know they
divorced in 1976 not surprisingly you
might have noticed a jump in the damn
video because I paused it to go eat
those pork chops
we were waiting like while we were
recording it yeah they were delicious
alright so as I said we are talking
about we're friendly getting to John
Wayne Casey's murderers yeah this is
where it gets interesting his before we
were just bullshitting I was just making
things up well he was doing terrible
[ __ ] yeah I gotta say this is like the
lead-up to the ocean so this is his
first alleged murder like I'm saying he
might have murdered more people for this
we don't know so this happened in very
early January of 1972
apparently Gacy picks up a 16 year old
boy named Timothy Jack McCoy from the
Greyhound bus terminal in Chicago now
this boy had been traveling from
Michigan to Omaha now Gacy said hey I'll
take you around like a saint teen tour
of Chicago and then you can stay at my
house and then you can let go the rest
of your way later on and the 60-mile boy
fell for that [ __ ] well he's 16 he's
traveling around 13 well this is 1972
though no can't do like you [ __ ] perv
I don't know what people need that back
then yeah so he's like yeah you can stay
at my house I'll Drive you to the stage
in the morning he can catch the bus and
go on to UM har whatever JC had a
tendency to blame other people for his
actions yeah so he his story was that he
picked up this kid he admitted that he
that he picked up the kid and he'd taken
him back to the house and whatnot he
says that he woke up the next morning
and found the kid standing in his
bedroom doorway with a knife yeah I buy
it so it was like self-defense yeah yeah
he's trying to explain why he did that's
what I mean so he's saying well because
Gacy apparently had like a scar in his
forearm and he's like yeah look that's
what that kid did he like cut me with a
knife and everything
that may be why maybe why I was
struggling for his life that's kind of
yeah I'm leaning toward that yeah so he
says that he killed this kid in
self-defense
you know I mean it was dangerous 16 year
old little white boys right so he kills
this kid and he buries him in the
crawlspace yeah and covers his grave
with a layer of concrete yeah now after
he was arrested KC reportedly said that
after he had killed Timothy McCoy who
was apparently his first victim he felt
quote totally drained but also he'd had
like the best orgasm ever and then he
realized that death was the ultimate
thrill that is another quote hmm so
later on that month he decided he was
going to commit another crime
now this victim was never identified he
was a teenage boy all they know about
him was that he was between 14 and 18
years old and that he had medium brown
hair and that Gacy picked him up
somewhere strangled him and then stored
his body in the closet prior to burial
hmm now Gacy later said that fluid
started leaking out of the kids mouth
and nose as he was in the closet because
it's a corpse yo yeah and it was like
messing up his carpet all right
so he's like okay well from now on I'm
gonna start putting like cloth rags or
their own underwear in their mouths to
keep that from happening like to keep
the bodies from leaking how long had you
been in there before they started
happening
I don't know this is this is a a an
alarming lack that tells not easy it
tells me he's also a damn necrophile
he's keeping the body around he's giving
me some Dahmer vibes on this yeah he's
keeping a body running like he he's
basically keeping he's keeping them in
the closet because I know that one of
them he kept under his bed for at least
24 hours before he buried in the
crawlspace cuz he did like very much the
crawlspace and then later famously when
he ran her broom in the crawlspace after
25 26 bodies
he started dumping them and the Des
Plaines River um I feel like he probably
kept some of them around house keeping
those purposes but I don't think as far
as I know he never admitted to that but
like we said with the Ted Bundy they
always lie I always lay about that it
was like they'll admit to rape and
murder and everything else but
necrophilia that's like it's like
crossing the line yeah that's like a
little just a little bit too far which
is that's very interesting it must be
something about it that is something
about doing that that even to them is
really [ __ ] all that [ __ ] man once
you are like great to murdered somebody
it's like you think necrophilia would be
like no big there's something about the
act but that is in a way kind of even
crossing the line for them they don't
want to talk about it they want to deny
that I said weird [ __ ]
I feel like that might have happened in
this way that must be [ __ ] they must
just kind of repulsed by it in a way or
something but they're drawn to it that's
just weird
I'm just not gonna I'm just not gonna
believe that you just keep somebody in
your closet for a few or a few for three
or four maybe five days or a week just
because there's a motive for that well
yeah I keep them you know what these
flowers you keep that around with these
guys there's always the whole thing as a
sexual motive so they're [ __ ] that
day by that's why it's in there
I think positively and it started to
leak because it was getting old you
cannot in there for too long yeah and he
knew it was leaking because he kept
checking on it what was he thinking well
he's in there [ __ ] getting that
little kid after he's dead and these
guys was getting kind of old but he
wants to get a couple more days out of
it
that's a weird [ __ ] well yeah I mean
from a serial-killer standpoint they're
probably thinking well I went to all the
trouble
right yeah Muslim Mexican napping and
raping and murdering this person I might
as well like you said maximize I'm gonna
max this out right that's my pleasure
they're thinking and then they're like
they're like they're probably gonna be
like oh the Green River Killer [ __ ]
what was his name
Gary ready yeah Ridge would be like
Ridgeway where they kind of build up a
tolerance to the smell I guess um turn
around so like you take you going back
in a summer you know like a month later
that shit's rotten yeah it's gonna be
some [ __ ] [ __ ] like that man yeah
yeah yeah it takes a special kind of
person and by special I mean you know
that kind of special what was weird is
that the investigators at the time
didn't grill him on that you'd be like
why are you keeping the body in there
for that amount of time yeah there's not
like a lot of necrophilia talk about AC
even though there was about Bundy yeah
no they were like even though he's in
Idaho
why are you putting the damn underwear
in the mouth so you can keep it in there
for a few more days yeah yeah so the
fluid doesn't lis yeah yeah you gonna
leak your fluid into this so the fluid
doesn't leak out of that you know
they're gonna play that kind of game why
yeah why not just bury it yeah because
he was burying them under his house
eventually not like it's not like he's
like doesn't have time right it doesn't
like all I can't run this one outside
there but they're watching no he's gonna
put him underneath the house why doesn't
he do it immediately why it's still
fresh well you dictate kitchen that's
the answer
yeah he's gonna use it up gonna maximize
it he definitely does seem like that
kind of killer yeah
where is he going back he's using that
sextile he's going back putting in
positions and all kind of [ __ ] gross
yeah yeah well it's [ __ ] rotten so
this body which as far as I know to this
day has
identified yeah was found out in his
backyard later on well you know they
know who that is
somebody's looking for him somebody's
look they just never matched up yeah
that's that body it's like obviously
that's somebody somebody was looking for
it but they just don't know it is him I
don't know which one so at this stage
1975 apparently Casey's business is
contracting business is very successful
he's working very many hours now
what he also started to do and he freely
admitted this in 1975 was he started
like basically cruising for teenage boys
he even calls this his cruising years or
his cruising time period or whatever
yeah they all do that yeah so the
business that he was running like I said
he ostensibly said that it was because
he was saving money and taxes and
payroll and [ __ ] like that because he
was hiring high school kids but you know
what the real [ __ ] right deal with
that was so he apparently so he hires a
15 year old named Anthony
Antonucci now this this kid was hired in
May of 1975 now in July of 1975 Gacy
turns up at this kid's house when the
kid was home alone and the kid was
apparently home sick because I guess he
had like hurt his foot at work or
whatever so Gacy brings over a bunch of
booze and gets the kid drunk then
wrestled him to the floor and cuffed his
hands behind his back now because the
one of the cuffs was like not all that
tight so Anthony got loose and so he
started now Anthony was on the high
school wrestling team so he wasn't a
pushover now he like got his hand free
and he jumped on Gacy when Casey came
back into the room and basically
compressing them to the ground and
caught the handcuff key off of him the
one that got away yeah apparently yeah
so he's like okay so Casey's like
alright well I'll leave if you take the
hand cuz because apparently aunt Anthony
had taken the handcuffs off himself and
put them back on Casey yeah and then he
was kind of like so you know good for
that kid
so apparently like Casey says to the kid
and this is what he remembers he says
not only are you the one who got out of
the cuffs you got them on me hmm so that
was like a big deal to me
yeah yeah a week later which was July
31st 1975 another one of gay C's
employees John boutté kovitch who was 18
years old disappeared now a day before
this boot kovitch had threatened Gacy
because Gacy apparently owed him two
weeks back pay so there had been like a
huge fight about this now later on after
Gacy was arrested he admitted that he
had lured Vukovich to his house while
his wife and stepchildren were away in
Arkansas visiting relatives and he said
that he like got him to the house he's
like oh well we'll talk about the pay
that I'm supposed to give you and that
I'm not gonna give you we're gonna like
have a meeting about that so boot
kovitch comes to the house and once he
gets there he does the thing where he's
like he did that trick where he's like
hey here's that magic trick in the with
the handcuffs and everything like that
and apparently he did that so that
worked and at one point like boot
kovitch got strangled and he was buried
under the floor of his garage now do we
know what he did do you need these guys
after he strangled her because one guy
got away and there was all kinds of like
the torture and [ __ ] before he did do
all kinds of sexual torture so you can
assume that because a
full of people that got away or that
were released by gazing before they were
killed
you can assume that he was probably
doing this as well so apparently so
he murdered boot kovitch and he left the
kids car which was a Dodge sedan he left
it in a parking lot with the kids wallet
still in there and the keys in the
ignition
look at Pookie hey stop it Oh Pookie
she's gonna be on the show yes she's mad
what yeah she is mad mad yes you want to
talk into the microphone Polk no she's
like why do you why why do you go turn
the paper over there mom okay so what
happen you like the show alright so my
god yeah so boot Capuchin sedan was
found abandoned in the parking lot with
the wallet and the car keys still in the
ignition now his family thought this was
a little weird as you would
so since Gacy was one of the last people
to have seen him because apparently the
kid had told him and he's like hey I'm
going to John Wayne Gacy 'he's house who
would who he had been working for he's
like i'm gonna talk to him about the
back-pay that he was me
so the kid's father calls Gacy and Gacy
says oh well you know I'll help you look
for him but he just like ran off you
know how kids do today so that's kind of
like what he said he just said yeah they
did come here and we like talked about
it but we like got to a compromise and
then he said off that's basically what
he said and nobody like followed up on
that to be fair to this kid's parents
they were super suspicious and they kept
calling the cops and said hey why don't
you like investigate this guy and the
cops didn't really do it like I said
it's the 70s they didn't look into his
background I guess not until much later
and right which well back in those days
there wasn't some kind of centralized
computer records I mean
yeah you probably wouldn't have found
anything on him maybe but you know
probably been like a eight-year quest of
trying to find it the guys damn record
back then yeah what's in another state
he was convicted it it was yeah it was
yeah they probably haven't found it
that's what I mean they don't they don't
look unless they're looking specifically
for that yeah you know so which is a
shame like it's easier nowadays like I
said I know the state it's harder for
you to get away with [ __ ] nowadays yeah
so apparently he's with his second wife
at this point now they have a huge fight
about apparently she was supposed to
like keep all the books for his business
and she didn't do it right or some kind
of [ __ ] and so they had a huge fight
about that and then they filed for
divorce in October of 1975 now the wife
kept living at the house and then until
February of 1976 and then her and the
two daughters cuz she had two daughters
from a previous marriage and then they
moved to their own apartment so it's
funny because the grounds that she gave
for divorce word that he had like [ __ ]
around her with other women even though
I'm pretty sure that she knew it was
boys that it was boys yeah I mean he did
like early on like he did seem to like
[ __ ] around with like Pross like female
prostitutes and stuff like that so it's
possible he could have still been doing
that but it does seem like what he's
looking for
yeah it does seem like boys were kind of
most of his thing now after he got
divorced
in March of 1976 it seems like even
though his neighbors had been kind of
like you know thinking he was a cool guy
and [ __ ] like that like I said he had
barbecues and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so they didn't they thought he was
just like a normal guy but they did
notice that he started acting a little
weird like after his wife took off they
said you know he was like out at all
hours it's like you know there was
always like young dudes like hanging
around the house and [ __ ] like that
and one neighbor even reported that they
thought they heard muffled screaming
coming from his house
although I guess it wasn't bad enough
that they thought to report it right but
you know just saying
so from 1976 to 1978 after her Casey's
wife left is what he called his cruising
years and this was the years where he
did most of his murders because he had
the house to himself and he could just
basically hey the woman left yeah so
that means you could just do whatever
the [ __ ] you want
yeah so this was one the majority of his
murders were committed so a month after
his divorce is finalized in March of
1976 he abducted and murdered an 18 year
old named Darrell Sampson it was last
seen alive in Chicago in April early
April of 1976 a little more than a month
later there was a 15 year old named
Randall ref it he was walking home from
high school and he disappeared later he
was found gagged with a cloth and he
died of asphyxiation now a few hours
after he disappeared there was a 14 year
old boy named Samuel Stapleton who also
disappeared as he was walking home from
his sister's house these two children
were later found buried in the same
grave underneath [ __ ] Casey's house
June 3rd 1976 Gacy kills a 17 year old
named Michael Bannen who was traveling
from Chicago to Waukegan Illinois he was
found strangled with a ligature and
buried in the crawlspace 10 days later
so he's not leaving a lot of space in
between these he's just basically going
on a [ __ ] rampage because his wife
left so you see how that goes
yes so sixteen-year-old kid named
William Carroll
he was also abducted and murdered and he
was buried under Casey's kitchen between
June 13th and August 6th there were
three unidentified children who were fat
who were you know abducted and murdered
like I said they still don't know who
they
are to this day they were between 16 and
17 years old during this time period
Gacy also killed a 16 year old named
James hakonsen who he was last known to
be alive on August 5th because he called
his family there was also a 17 year old
named Rick Johnston last seen alive on
August 6th what are you doing
knock it off a bit go now in July of
1976 late July
so Gacy has been this is one of his like
sticks is that he'll you know offer work
with his contracting company which was a
successful contracting company to
teenage boys and he was paying at the
time the princely sum of $5 an hour
which was like twice as much as most
other places were paying what are you
doing to attack the paper yeah she's
trying to attack venue which is twice as
much as most places were paying so it's
like you can see how kids would fall for
that because he was like a respected
member of the community and he had a
company which he did and he was like so
he was hiring people so he hires this 18
year old named David kram now David kram
moves into his house in August of 1976
now the day after he was hired
Gacy does his trick of like hey here's a
trick and I'm like I'm gonna put like
[ __ ] handcuffs on you right so
apparently the cuffs are on this guy and
Gacy says to him hey I'm gonna rape you
David kram says yeah I don't think so
because he's been in the Army so he
turns the [ __ ] around on him and [ __ ]
gets back at Gacy so he gets out of the
handcuffs how does he do that I don't
know I said I guess he just like muscled
his way out of there yeah yeah now the
weird thing about it though is this
where he like wonder why is that David
kram like still kept working for the guy
like afterward like for a long time
afterward because apparently he was
still living there
like a month later you take it seriously
I guess I guess not because Casey comes
to his bedroom door and says well you
better let me rape you or you know you
don't know who I am that kind of crap
right and so Davis like yeah whatever
it's like I don't think he really took
it all that seriously he didn't seem to
like I said he did leave the company at
some point but he still did some work
for the guy so I guess he wasn't seeing
him as a threat
now a short little guy he wasn't I mean
like you know he didn't seem all that
intimidating five five or something he
just seemed like a normal dude so
another guy moves in Michael Rossi he
moves into the house as well now between
August and October 1976 two other
unidentified males are thought to have
been killed in these in this house one
of the like William Carroll was buried
there he had been murdered on June 13th
and there was also the body of Brooke
Johnston who was last seen on August 6th
there was another unidentified male who
like I said as far as I know was still
unidentified he was between 15 and 24
years old had light brown hair and he
was buried like in between the two of
them so they think that he might have
been killed between the two of them now
another thing that Gacy would do is that
the dudes that were working for him
there were already bodies buried in the
crawlspace right and he would tell them
to go down to the crawlspace and like
dig trenches down there because he was
like putting tile down there so he's
making like these [ __ ] teenage boys
gonna and dig essentially graves they
didn't know that at the time but it's
like he's like yeah I'm gonna like tile
down there like eventually so go down
there and dig some trenches but nobody
like realize what was going on so in
October of late October of 1976 he
kidnapped and killed two other teenage
boys Kenneth Parker and Michael Moreno
both at the same time he like I guess he
saw them outside a restaurant and lured
them into his car
they were both strangled and buried in
the same crawl space two days after that
a 19 year old employee of his William
Bundy also disappeared after he had told
his family that he was going to a party
he was also strangled and buried in the
crawlspace yet another employee of gay
C's not real smart this dude he just
keeps like hiring teenage boys and them
yeah like they'll never put it together
that if yeah well I mean he he wasn't
that dumb because it took him a really
long time to like put it together
weirdly because another one of his
employees disappeared in December of
1976 this was 17 year-old Gregory
Cossack now his girlfriend and he had
actually like dropped his girlfriend off
like outside her house they had had a
date or whatever and that was the last
time he was seen he had been working for
Gacy for three weeks when he disappeared
and he had also prior to his
disappearance had told his family that
he had dug trenches under there so he
was apparently digging his own grave
which is [ __ ] up they found his car
abandoned later on now the shitty thing
like I said and this seems to be like a
kind of common thread and why they
didn't catch Gacy for so long is that he
would basically say oh these teenage
boys in the 70s they like oh they just
run away and like yeah and the cops were
like okay yeah I guess so it's the 70s
which I guess a lot of them did but it's
like you have to kind of like question
there are so many dudes there are so
many teenage boys like working for this
guy that are disappearing yeah you would
think that somebody would have put that
[ __ ] together I mean this is a very
brief time period it was another time it
was another I guess Sam so only a month
later January 20th 1977 there's another
guy named John psych
he was 19 year olds and he was like a
friend
of a couple of the other dudes that had
worked for Gacy he also disappeared now
he was actually gonna sell his car to
gays he or so that was like the story
and then he was never seen again after
that so over the next couple of months
several other men who were either
employed by Gacy or in Gacy Circle
mysteriously disappeared you can
probably guess where they all ended up
underneath that damn basement underneath
the floorboards yeah yeah during this
time period he also became engaged to
this woman that he kind of knew but that
was like broken off after only a couple
of months and only a cup and only a
month after that he apparently killed
another young man named Matthew Bowman
now in late 1977 December 30th he
actually kidnapped a 19 year old named
Robert Donnelly from a Chicago bus stop
this young man was raped and tortured
and had his head repeatedly dunked into
a bathtub until he passed out and then
Casey would revive him and he kept like
doing that and apparently he did it so
many times that the guy just kept saying
to Gacy just go ahead and kill me like
get it over with just because it was so
[ __ ] horrible
and apparently Gacy said to him I'll get
around to it
damn yeah yeah so that's [ __ ] special
so now like I said there are so many I
can't even like I feel bad that I can't
like name all the Vics it's like so
[ __ ] many 33 33 33 people and some of
them are not identified so I made there
six of them how do they know that he did
that wait John must have said what
happened to him
he did but like they found well they
found all the bodies yeah but I'm
talking about the drowning the guy yeah
well yeah jobless on the only witness
therefore this survivor although and
I'll get into this in a bit some people
have
theorized that he might have had an
accomplice or more than one accomplice
because they note that some people that
they know that John Wayne John Wayne
Gacy killed
disappeared when he was provably out of
town and one of the people who one of
the victims who survived said that he
had seen someone else like watching his
torture yeah I remember that yes so some
people have thought that maybe he had
like [ __ ] accomplices
which you know not crazy I don't know
so March of 1978 John Wayne Gacy lures a
26 year old named Jeffrey Jeffrey
written all into his car now he
chloroform's the guy and then he drives
him to the house he was raped and
tortured with various instruments
including lit candles whips and whatnot
every time he would wake up John Wayne
Gacy would chloroform him again and then
he then gay sea drives him to Lincoln
Park and he dumped him out apparently he
thought he was dead but he wasn't
so regnal wakes up and he gets to his
girlfriend's apartment now what ended up
happening with this and this guy
probably contributed more to gay see
getting caught than anybody else because
because of all the chloroform that had
been used one his face was all burned
from the chloroform also he had been
given so much chloroform that his liver
was permanently damaged and as he would
be he was really [ __ ] pissed off
about that and he wanted to catch the
person that did this to him so for many
months afterward he staked out the area
where he was taken from looking for that
[ __ ] car and eventually he saw it
because Gacy had a very distinctive it
was a like a black Cadillac or something
like that so Rick null was just like sit
at this [ __ ] highway exit waiting for
this car and one day he saw it and when
he saw it he wrote down the
[ __ ] license plate number and he
reported it to the cops so good for him
yeah like I said he was [ __ ] mad at me
he's like he's like I said his liver was
destroyed like permanently so Gacy gets
arrested on July 15th and this is a
battery charge because they got him on
the brignall answer but he didn't die so
it was just like they didn't know they
didn't know where they didn't have
enough evidence like you know get him on
any of the other murders they just had
him on this kind of [ __ ] so he gets
arrested for that so now other than this
guy like [ __ ] staking out the dude it
could be argued that one of the things
that contributed to Gacy finally getting
arrested because this is kind of shitty
and we talk about this a lot when we
talk about like serial killers the
target prostitutes and stuff like that I
kind of feel like a lot of his earlier
victims while not I mean they weren't
homeless or anything like that but it
seems like the public perception of them
was oh they were just runaways I got my
friend justice or whatever but the fact
is that one of the things that got him
caught was the fact that he kidnapped a
kind of a middle class kid named Robert
priest now the [ __ ] up thing was
Robert priest was he was 15 years old he
worked at a pharmacy and his mom had
just was picking him up from work and
the kid literally goes to his mom and
says hey I gotta talk to this guy about
a job who was John Wayne Gacy like I
said he was offering like five dollars
an hour which was a lot of money back in
1978 and he's like I'll be right back
and the mom is like sure and she's like
wandering around the pharmacy like
waiting for the kid and then clearly you
know it does not come back
so Gacy just like [ __ ] snatched him
from the pharmacy where he worked while
his mom was [ __ ] waiting for him no
yeah huh I wonder how he did that
I [ __ ] knows well like I said somehow
well yeah because it's not due out well
he was a contractor and he was like oh
well you know I have a job for you that
was how we got a lot of kids into his
car and then he had like chloroform he
had rope he had handcuffs he had all
this other kind of [ __ ] so then he would
like [ __ ] disable you when she got in
the car or once you got to his house he
was all about and from everything that
I've heard about him he was very good at
convincing people to do what he wanted
yeah because he seemed very normal
must have got the kid in a position that
chloroformed him or something handcuffed
that's I kind of feel like that's
probably what he did so it's kind of
shitty because it seems like the fact of
this kid disappearing I'm not saying
that some of the cops in Chicago didn't
suspect there was some [ __ ] going on
because they said look there's a lot of
like disappearances revolving around
this guy or like in this dude circle but
it almost like it seemed like it was
this dude I don't remember I don't
remember Gacy is being physically
powerful at all though remember he was
kind of dumpy looking wasn't he he was
but like chloroform and like other kind
of [ __ ] like that was he like five five
five I have no idea but yeah so it
really does seem like it's sad but so
many so many people had disappeared but
it seemed like it took robber priests
disappearance before they really even
though like I said to their credit a lot
of cops had been suspecting but they
couldn't really do anything about it
well they were just working-class kids
and they were just disappear and there
was no body see yeah and that's what
open investigation and some of the
parents like complained and I've seen
some like documentaries some of the
parents were complaining they're like
look we went to the cops and said look
our kid wouldn't do that and they're
like oh they just ran away that's
teenage boys do that [ __ ] all the time
that's basically what they said to them
but when Robert priests disappeared and
his family was like look he would not do
that he didn't have any reason to
disappear he had a job he had a bright
future he had like all this stuff coming
up and well that's it
credibility to it yeah the man that
could have been the Gacy was going after
kids that kind of had ruff homes anyway
he was so he's going like well if I take
this one they'll just think that he ran
away from that house yeah yeah so and it
seems that the police did kind of do
believe for a while right
but once Robert Reese disappeared
finally the cops were like look you know
his family is like thinking this is not
you know kosher and they were already
beginning to suspect because there was
so much like chatter about Gacy like at
the fringes of all these disappearances
right so they're kind of like thinking
maybe we should do something about so
finally finally they do a background
check and they find that he had served a
prison sentence in Iowa for sodomy on
the fifteen-year-old boy
as previously mentioned so using this as
you know their evidence they got a
warrant to search his house and they
find all kind of suspicious things they
find a high school class ring which is
engraved with initials jas which was the
initials of a another person that had
been missing they found a bunch of
driver's licenses they found some weird
porn they found a bunch of handcuffs
they found a 2x4 with holes drilled in
the ends books on homosexuality books on
pederasty they found a bunch of male
clothing that obviously would not fit
John Wayne Gacy they found a some guns
and [ __ ] like that and most
significantly they found a photo receipt
from the pharmacy where Robert peaced
worked later on they found out that one
of Robert Pease co-workers had put this
murder receipt into the pocket of Robert
piece jacket so this photo receipt being
at Casey's house gave them probable
cause because they said they is like how
would he have this at his house right in
you know if he had not interacted with
him on this particular day so at this
stage they decide they're going to put
her under put Gacy under surveillance
now the thing about gays
and I feel like he was like super cocky
and [ __ ] like that he knew he was under
surveillance because apparently the cops
weren't all that sneaky about it so he
would do [ __ ] like like I said tell-tale
heart style he would like invite them to
come in the house and have dinner with
him he would invite them to bars and
have drinks and [ __ ] like that
almost like daring them did he do bail
from that coming from this it's weird
because later on one of the cops who had
searched the house you know the first
time like when they found all this other
stuff he did say that he smelled
something weird but it didn't really
occur to him this time that it could be
a bunch of Buffy right which we had all
that lime on him I guess I guess but
it's like he just thought it smelled bad
and he asked Gacy about it but like I
said Gacy just said oh it's like really
damp down there in bloody black so
apparently all after all of this
surveillance uh the whole time that Gacy
was under surveillance they could see
that he was visibly stressed out they
said he was gaining weight he was like
not shaving he was like looking like he
wasn't sleeping and all this other kind
of stuff so they could tell that he was
worried about some [ __ ] so they have him
in custody and this is December 20th and
he goes
Gacy goes to his lawyer's office and
they're talking about some civil suit
that they were trying to settle with
like you know one of the disappearances
or whatever
now Jacey asks for some whiskey which
they give him and then he says to his
lawyer that the boy is dead one of the
boys that were asking about his bodies
in the river he then said I've been the
judge jury and executioner of many many
people
at which point his lawyer promptly [ __ ]
himself
because he was he wasn't expecting this
was gay C's lawyer you don't have to
imagine
and suddenly Gacy is saying yeah I did
all I did all this [ __ ] you
basically so he says that yeah there's a
whole bunch of them buried in my
crawlspace under my house and after I
ran into space there I started dumping
them in the Des Plaines River now he
tried to mitigate it somewhat by saying
that they had all tried to hustle him or
lie to him or something like that like
they always [ __ ] had it coming
thirty-plus justifiable homicides pretty
much what he's trying to say yeah I
didn't tell anybody but I didn't report
it he's basically saying that they all
they all deserved had it coming
yeah so after he said all that they
searched his home yet again mm-hmm duh
and started looking in the crawl space
under the floor birds and started
phoning all hond Skelton somebody's
[ __ ] body why they didn't find them
before who knows Otto look I guess ah I
guess not yeah it's like the [ __ ] up
thing is I ever heard of John Wayne Gacy
so they didn't check the didn't know
it's like yeah they started looking in
the house and they started they said the
one guy that I saw the documentary is
like we [ __ ] peeled up the floorboard
and it's like there was just we just
started like there was just [ __ ]
skeletons I yeah we're 2627 em and it's
like after that like after they found
all those people they were still looking
for a robert priest who was you know the
missing person that had kind of like
engendered this whole [ __ ]
investigation they did another finding
him until like much later on he wasn't
buried into the house because like I
said Casey this is so [ __ ] up he ran
at a room under his house he thought he
said it first he's like oh well I was
gonna put them in the Attic but then I
thought they would like drip balls yeah
yeah so he's like so I just thought I
would put them under the [ __ ] floor
and like he just thought they were gone
he just like buried them under there
like threw some lime on there and didn't
[ __ ] think about it anymore
yeah people complained about the smell
but he just said oh you know the sump
pump is backed up or he can't like came
up with some excuse living on top of a
cemetery
yeah there's like [ __ ] bodies
underneath your [ __ ] house holy crap
it's like yeah and then they went and
searched the they went drag the disk
plains river and found like several
other victims that he had said were
there so that can't be too common cuz
they tear down houses all the time and
don't find [ __ ] tons of dead bodies
underneath them anymore well I hope so
this isn't something that happens
[ __ ] you know just like talking about
it it's not common well that's good
though yeah think about it that's good
though
no I'm just thinking how many houses
there are in the United States yeah
they come many more have bodies under
yeah yeah how many of them they tear
down a year and how many bodies do they
find you don't hear about it no well
like I said hopefully it's rare yeah I
guess it's got to be very rare either
that if the house has been there for a
long time then it gets eaten eventually
the skeleton itself in certain climates
would go would kind of turn to dust
wouldn't it it takes a long time well no
because they found skeletons from like
thousands of year Roman period yeah so
it's like they don't turn to dust it
takes like a really long time for that's
I thought maybe if there was groundwater
that might it depends on the conditions
yeah but they found like decompose and
skeletonized bodies underneath his
[ __ ] house and they found so many
that eventually they were just like
[ __ ] they just tore the whole house
yeah oh yeah by that house
yeah here the [ __ ] yeah and I've ever
seen photographs of and video of it it
wasn't all that you know the house
wasn't it was just like it shot it just
shocks me that this that's the thing
that always freaks me out is that people
came to barbecues at his house like all
his neighbors were like [ __ ] and
there was like [ __ ] dead kids under
his house so what else so what else
whole time how'd the trial go down what
happened next well basically what
happened at the trial was that he had
already confessed right and he confessed
to the 33 like they found all the bodies
under his house clearly although he kind
of implied that it's like oh well maybe
you know one of my roommates did it
which may
there's some like truth to that because
some of the people like some of the
victims did disappear while he was out
of town and one of the victims did say
that they had seen someone else like
watching the [ __ ] I don't know if I buy
it or not because Gacy was kind of full
of [ __ ] but um you know so there was
that so there was that whole thing so he
tried to kind of say that it's like oh
it was my roommate they had keys to my
house they were like there they were
killing and burying people at my [ __ ]
house when I didn't know it's like I I
find that hard to believe
yeah guys imagine the cops laughed when
they say this but yes so I'm not saying
he didn't have accomplices I'm just
saying the fact that it's oh I'm totally
innocent and people were just burying
bodies under my house and when I wasn't
there and I didn't know anything about
it yeah I'm not buying that not at all
but he tried to do that now his defense
like I said he had already confessed but
then like later he came out and said
yeah didn't do that [ __ ] it was somebody
else
so his defense like what could they do
they tried to pull insanity however yes
it's like they you know they had all
these psychologists um you know analyze
him and stuff like that yes he obviously
had mental problems you know clearly but
because of the testimony of a bunch of
his employees that said that we had been
down in the crawlspace and we were
digging you know trenches that
essentially were Grave sized so that
showed forethought which means that you
couldn't have necessarily been insane
because you knew that you would have to
you you were pre-planning and you knew
you would have to get rid of bodies and
hide them which means that you pretty
much knew what you were doing so so
during the trial it's like it seems like
it only took a couple of hours for the
jurors to pretty much come back and go
nah son yeah I think it took two every
way you're not talking about you and
there's like he tried but you know what
I mean so yeah they came back and I
think it only took another two hours
before they came back during the
sentencing
phase of the trial and said yeah give
him the [ __ ] death penalty most of
the victims parents were all on board
with that as well because you have to
imagine that a lot of the victims
families their loved ones their sons had
been missing for several years at this
point and they didn't know where they
were so it's like when all these bodies
started turning up like underneath this
douches house you know they were waiting
to see if that was their kid because
they knew that it's like that was the
last person that had seen them or that
was you know what I mean so most of the
like I saw a bunch of the the mothers of
the of the victims like on there they
were just like yeah just [ __ ] fry
they do like I said before the weird
thing about it though it's like [ __ ]
Gacy was on death row for 14 years he
went through like all the appeals that
you go through um he apparently like he
had a good time on death row I guess
like a lot of the time that he was in
there he was really trying to he studied
law he looked was like trying to wangle
his way out of it essentially it seemed
like fantasizing and the whole time even
though he had confessed to like 33
murders and they think he might have
done more because he said something like
because they asked him we'll have you
killed any more people and he's like oh
well that's for you guys to find out or
something like that so it's like whether
he killed any more I don't know but they
found 33 bodies that they know he did
but he was like trying to like [ __ ]
wangle his way out of it so like I said
he's he's like appealing appealing
appealing he got denied every single
time like I said they finally gave him
his [ __ ] you know final execution
date night which was in 1994 and he
talked to his [ __ ] lawyer saying he
still got the [ __ ] papers like he
thinks he's gonna be exonerated and he's
like oh I'll call you in like two hours
look even though his [ __ ] brother was
like an hour before now just like in the
case of Ted Bundy when he was executed
by electric chair there was a huge crowd
the prison and the majority of the
people there were some people there that
were like opposed to the death penalty
oh they were party and I remember that
but yeah the the majority of the people
were like super they even had they had
shirts made that said no tears for the
clown yeah yeah they were all they were
just like when Ted Bundy got execute I
remember that because I was in Florida
you know they were out there just like
[ __ ] fry the dude or whatever they
were um you know so [ __ ] Gacy goes to
the chair asserting his innocence right
to the very end do you know what his
last words on earth were what's that
kiss my yeah yeah also denote his last
meal was what was this KFC for a chicken
okay yeah which he had worked there for
many years and I can't see but you know
it isn't messed up it's like every time
I'm kind of fascinated with what people
that are going to the death you know to
the electric chair or whatever it's like
I'm always fascinated by what their last
meal is I guess a lot of other people
are too I guess that's why they tell
people what it was because it's like
what would I eat if I knew I was gonna
die it's just Monday later in the same
day they probably just don't offer him
just any old thing cuz man you could eat
whatever you wanted cuz it's like you
don't have to worry about getting fat or
like it's a shake or anything they're
just running up the street to the local
[ __ ] restaurants and that are outside
the prison
they're probably give him a choice I
would think that like people that worked
at the prison or people that cooked in
the prison would be like man [ __ ] this
[ __ ] you know I mean why would they
like want to go all out to like make
something taste nice for somebody that
was cake executed I don't think I don't
think they'd say anything I think the
cops just go down there you know run
down there and run dude they just gonna
pick it up no yeah he just pick it up
probably yeah
but yeah that was his last meal was KFC
and I think he had strawberry shortcake
or something like that but yeah that was
his last word that was my ass so like I
said in later years now in 2012 they
actually announced another kind of push
to identify because I believe at least
six of his
items are were unidentified as of now so
they are still actively trying to like
identify those six victims must have
been from out of state maybe they had
something dude that supposed to suppose
it accomplished that he had yeah that
got coral yeah coral name coral you
ain't even didn't he he had that teenage
mmm-hmm gopher mmm-hmm maybe it's a
situation like that it does seem like
that's because one of the dudes that got
raped and that but he got us he escaped
he said later on even though he had been
chloroformed and he was like unconscious
some of the time he did say that there
was another like teenage two young adult
male yeah that was like there and it was
like seemed like he was watching the
festivities and there was some
festivities and was like around in the
area so there have been ongoing yeah
theories that he might have had an
accomplice any problem like I said Gacy
said that he did it's like nobody buys
anything that [ __ ] Gacy said cuz
everyone knows that he was full of [ __ ]
but he might have had a Dean Corll style
sidekick it could have been it was
getting other guys and bringing them
there and eventually eventually the the
sidekick was killed - he's underneath
the damn [ __ ] floorboards he was one
it might have been like maybe one of the
ones that was almost killed earlier like
he said like it seems like a Dean Corll
situation it might have been something
like that but he killed that kid too and
that that kid was the one that got the
other five unidentified ones yeah maybe
that kid was like something from a juvie
home or something yeah it does seem like
that's probably what and like I said he
might have like blackmailed that kid
into the [ __ ] it's like hey you just pry
out started yeah go along with this [ __ ]
or I'll kill you - then he got sorry to
him and killed raped and killed him put
him underneath there to cover his tracks
and then it really raised the identity
of the other father it wouldn't shock me
and like I said this is the early 7
early to mid 70s and you know he
targeted teenage boys that were looking
for work or you know looking for drugs
or looking for a porn or whatever
and six seven were probably those never
six that were unidentified with probably
one of them is at least one of maybe
sidekick and they probably something
from kind of like an an underground
criminal underground gang of [ __ ]
teenage kids something like that they're
a runaway something like that yeah
little underage drug dealers something
like that but yeah the thing about Gacy
too and I think a lot of people probably
know this but while he was on death row
he started doing all those paintings
like he did some of Jesus he did some of
like the Seven Dwarfs yeah he did a
bunch of like Coco the clown which are
supremely creepy yeah but that [ __ ] on
purpose well for a while he was making I
don't know if he was making money
directly off of them but people were
buying their panem so yeah I think you
have the right to sell your own art well
I don't see I don't know like nowadays
made back then you could like nowadays
I'm not sure what the laws in the US it
might be different state to state
because I know that in the UK there was
a thing where I can't remember what
murderer it was but they made a thing
where it's like because he was like
trying to write a book and like make all
this money like I'm gonna write a book
about like all the murderers I did and
they were like yeah no no no you're not
gonna do that if if any money comes from
it it has to go to like a victim fund
that's profiting off your crime that's
what I mean I don't think you could do
that anymore
the thing is though is that in the
American system it wouldn't be profiting
off a crime because selling a painting
has nothing to do with your crime that's
how that's how they're gonna look at it
in the law well like I said it's
probably different from state to state
yeah because I feel like people did like
by them I was reading this thing on it
was on murder PDA I think and it was
like this one guy that had gone to visit
him a bunch of times and he had actually
bought one of his paintings and he was
even saying it's like I'm not really
sure like where that money put I went to
a lawyer I went into his accountant it
went to so he could buy a candy off the
[ __ ] commissary
that's all they can't buy anything
that's not on that damn commissary list
that's true it's not like they can
really like it
bought candy it's not like they're
living high on the hog on boxing death
rounds yeah he [ __ ] bought some damn
sodas and some [ __ ] potato chips and
some cigarettes yeah something like that
yeah so this [ __ ] got
electrocuted in 1994 last words kiss my
ass that's super classy so uh you know
how long is this show going on it's like
it's only you guys all right so we are
going to are you ready to wrap it up was
it are you ready to wrap it wrap it up
all right
I like really truncated the last part of
this because we were really trying it's
gone it for like so long and then if we
got attacked by the cat it's like way
past midnight we're getting like a wrap
up the show on John Wayne Gacy hope you
guys enjoyed it you know how we do we
just like get drunk and start rambling
and whatever it was even though I
skipped a lot of stuff but it's it was
just a little technical [ __ ] they could
see on Wikipedia yeah it's fine so yeah
I hope you guys enjoyed episode 184
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
remember check us out on Instagram
that's a fairly new Instagram account so
you know we're trying to get everybody
to follow us on there also if you would
like to financially support the show it
is much appreciated place our [ __ ]
[ __ ] going blurry like every two seconds
it's don't worry about it um if you'd
like to financially support the show
would be much appreciated and go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
you can go to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast where Bruce calm and there is a
button in the sidebar that goes to a
PayPal account if you would like to give
a one-time donation also much
appreciated all all used to improve the
show and various other things
Rhona got that Kovac no dear he's got so
we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]